[Music]
okay let's hope that that is not
uh a bellwether of things to come it
shouldn't be
we don't know why it's happening we're
not pulling any power
not pulling any bandwidth i mean we're
and it's on a lan cable
yeah i just you know whatever yeah we
restarted the laptop and everything
technology hates me
is i think the problem here oh should
everything be updated and everything it
should be good
well yeah i updated everything i updated
this i updated
my vpn i updated everything okay so you
know
so where did it cut out it probably cut
out around the time where i was talking
about
young white girls with the first name
smith yeah
that was yeah because we were talking
about the cat that was named
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] rich rich people
[ __ ] naming their
naming their girls with [ __ ] last
names as first names well they did that
with kid with the boys too
like everybody everybody had to have a
last name as a first name
the first name [ __ ] conrad and then
the person
can't i had an uncle named conrad yeah
yeah pretty says conrad now that you
well i mean when you said conrad
and i was thinking about path kitty and
i was like yeah he does kind of look
like a conrad yeah
i thought he looked like a theodore but
like i said he looked like somebody that
had kind of like a distinguished like
old man kind of name
you know what i mean yeah so and he
definitely looked like a mr somebody
so i'm glad that they did actually name
him mr maguire because apparently they
thought the same thing that i thought
he looks like he has he has two names
you know what i mean
okay so we're back on chord
horror movies right yeah okay i even
downloaded i wanted i don't know if like
people are gonna do this but um
i was just kind of like oh if anybody
has any like horror trivia questions
that they want to ask me that like
so they think they're gonna like stump
me and stuff i would love that
but if you can come up with something i
was took i took like in preparation for
the show
i have a horror trivia game like on my
phone and i don't know you can ask me
oh look this horror trivia
game you can do a standard game or you
can do a drinking game
which this way that might be worth doing
um i took some quizzes like on youtube
like some people have put up some horror
quizzes and i took one that was supposed
to be like oh this really difficult one
or whatever and i think it was like 40
minutes long
and i only missed one yeah the only one
that i missed
was they had a little section where
they're like what you know they would
play a little bit of music and they say
you know what
movie is this the theme song to and
it played and i was like i could barely
hear it and i was like
i was like it kind of sounds familiar
but i couldn't think of what it was it
was saw
and i was like well i've seen that a
bunch of times but not enough that i
remember
it's not like the music from saw is like
super iconic or anything
but i think i got all the other ones
right though now that i'm thinking about
it
i kind of feel like a lot of the horror
movie quizzes that are online
even ones that said oh this is super
hard and everything like that and i
would like
take it and i'm just like this isn't
hard what are you even talking about
and i was watching this one youtube
channel that was just
i mean basically it was just three dudes
and they play board games so they're not
like horror fans or anything and even
one of them said that he didn't watch a
lot of horror movies
so they were playing a horror trivia
game on the thing
and i was just like yelling at them the
whole time because they were missing
like the simplest [ __ ] questions i'm
like you guys suck at this
i can't believe you don't know this
[ __ ] question and they can't hear me
you know
but you know yeah but jenny you would
not drink much well i
i would probably just drink just because
not because i missed a question
dj maniac says be happy i'm not making
you guys play the rob zombie drinking
game
yeah don't call him connie or you get
punched
uh camp guy is saying i like that one
texas chainsaw with matthew mcconaughey
wasn't that i think feel that was the
fourth one right like the new beginning
because wasn't renee zellweger in that
one too i've seen her forever
yeah this was well it came out like
before she
got really famous like with um you know
bridget jones diary and all of that
but um and it's funny because i feel
like
well renee zellweger i think if i'm
remembering it correctly is like barely
in it but of course since she got famous
afterwards so now every time that they
sell the
dvd they put her and matthew
mcconaughey's name like
really big like on the [ __ ] it's just
kind of like [ __ ] jennifer aniston
being in
leprechaun for whatever [ __ ]
leprechaun movie she was in
like when she was first starting out
like i said no shame it's like everybody
got to start somewhere a [ __ ] johnny
depp was in the first nightmare on elm
street when nobody knew who he was well
i guess he'd been on 21 jump street like
on tv
prior to that you know and even like um
man what was that one what's that one
[ __ ] movie called uh
that had a whole bunch of like [ __ ]
famous like holly hunter was in it
and uh what's the dude that was on
seinfeld
god damn it yes you what's the name what
was the name of the
the demon that was inside a reagan and
uh kazuzu
although they don't say it in the movie
though i don't think they say it in the
first movie
they might have said it in the second
one but i haven't seen the second one in
a long time because it was terrible
but the third one's awesome actually no
i thought uh
i thought the damon's the demon said his
own name didn't he
not in the first movie no not that i
remember
he doesn't say pazuzu okay i don't think
they said that until late and then it
became canon i mean they
show the little guy the little demon guy
he finds him like in iraq or whatever
but i don't think they ever say the name
pazuzu in the first movie
i think that was like a later
extrapolation it's kind of one of those
things
like the friday the 13th movies where
everybody remembers jason but nope
with the hockey mask but jason didn't
get the hockey mask until the third
[ __ ] movie
he had a [ __ ] bag he had a bag on his
head yeah like the phantom killer of
texarkana
in the second one and in the first one
it was his mom so
you know like i said even in even in
[ __ ] scream
he parodied that because that was one of
the questions that ghostface asked to
drew barrymore at the beginning
i got a lot of those friday the 13th
movies i think on the first three are
good
just gotta say well yeah and that's kind
of the case with any
and the thing about slasher movie they
weren't that good i love slasher movies
yeah but they you know they do get kind
of samey yeah
they have a formula and you have to be
in the mood for them
tila says you are correct coughing up
the super chat yeah
i kind of wanted to let me see what the
drinking game one of
this is let me see presley it's got like
a little music with it what is a
drinking game
so it's okay so we have halloween
special
regular or all let's do all
game game length 15 questions 25
questions 50 questions or what what
grampner says what species the bird was
packing at the innards of robert pat
patterson at the end of lighthouse well
it was a uh
wasn't it a seagull or like a seabird of
some kind wasn't it was it
or an albatross was it a seagull or an
albatross i can't remember he's asking
you i've only seen that movie one time
okay i'm just i'm saying
you yeah oh [ __ ] okay
oh damn i'm already no
seagull yeah i thought it was too yeah
and then i thought well
no maybe it's like albatross like in
[ __ ] whatever that uh
thing was so this this trivia game i got
this for 99 cents on google play
i don't know how many questions it is
it's 270 questions
yeah and um this is the drinking game
edition so i don't know if you get one
wrong like do you have to drink
like i'm gonna drink anyway but i'm just
saying
so the question is what year did the
bride of frankenstein get released
start starring people such as boris
karloff and valerie hopson
and okay um
all right i feel like that was maybe
1935.
is that right can i do it
it's not letting me do it okay
no it's just not working it's not
letting me do it
is that the wrong answer i don't know
okay it's just maybe it's just not
letting frozen
what the hell okay let me get back to
the show
[Music]
in the original wicker man what famous
starlet played the temptress
i want to say it was brit eckland but
i'm not sure if that's correct
the question they're giving me now oh
and this is bad because i don't think i
saw this
it doesn't work though it is it it might
what did the braille text
on julia's hand say in rings
i don't think i saw rings that was like
the
[ __ ] okay i'm gonna guess
it's not letting me do it i'm going to
have to start over yeah
besides they can't see it they're not
playing the game with you that's true
but i'm just saying well it's good to
have questions and then other people can
answer them
you know what i mean yeah okay i'm just
saying
don't don't no i'm just don't spoil my
phone i'm not split on your phone
[Laughter]
don't spoil my fun mute media okay we
can do that
uh i can't believe my package isn't here
yet well what do you i don't know what
you want me to do about it
what do you want me to do what do you
want me to do about it
was that right oh my god yeah
what's the name of ripley's cat oh
uh jones jonesy yeah
[Laughter]
if it's movie trivia i'll suck ass just
listen and see how nerdy you all are
i'm trying to get this game to work but
it's not like [ __ ] working
i don't know i would have got that wrong
anyway
i'm going to restart the phone let's see
what happens
oh that next question i know the answer
to that one
the name of ripley's cat was joe jones
yeah yeah
oh sophie's here
yeah so if he wants to see how nerdy we
are yeah i couldn't believe how nerdy i
was when i took some of the
quizzes uh online
and i was just kind of like man
and then i saw like the average one of
the one of the quote-unquote hard ones
was like the average score was like 73
and i got every single one of them right
so i was like well i guess i am a dork
who got infected oh this is a tough one
who got infected first
in john carpenter's the thing just was
it the old swede
yeah yeah wait wait there's no region
well wait a minute no no no no no
okay well technically the people in the
norwegian game i was getting
first yeah and then the dog
so the dog got him now yeah hold on yeah
he didn't get he didn't get affect
he got shot okay
the first person to get infected
you don't know well the dog got him the
dog
because the dog was infected the dog
came into the camp
and that was he was the one that made he
was already infected
right and then the guy who kept the dogs
i thought it was like the guy the
the um the guy like the the oatmeal guy
right diabetes that guy no
no he got infected much later that's
right
i don't think you know who who got
infected
pukes no they found fuchs dead he burned
himself
that is a hard one well
and plus you don't know how many like i
said it kind of keeps it ambiguous
because you're not supposed to know
there's a lot of stuff that's ambiguous
about the movie like who got infected
they're changing clothes during it so
you don't know how much time has passed
to from scene to scene sometimes yeah
yeah and see dj maniac said i never said
person see so i said the dog
i said or technically the norwegians
although now we're getting into
territory like this is like semantics
you know what i mean
the guy who kept the dogs no no he got
shot in the head and he never did turn
yeah that's right uh what's his what's
his name
crussell shot him crystal shot him
russell shot him right between the eyes
when he came at him with a knife
i remember correctly yeah remember when
keith david goes
say he was human which makes you a
murderer
yeah and [ __ ] crosstalk goes [ __ ] all
that okay the next
yeah this is not letting me like answer
the ques it was working earlier
maybe it's just not i don't know i don't
know what it's doing
well i would have got that right if you
were like letting me do it
but you know whatever all right well
this so that didn't work
what was the name of the escape shuttle
an alien
the escape shuttle the escape shuttle
was called um
the main ship was the nostromo yeah the
escape shuttle was uh
damn it we just watched it yeah i used
to know we just watched it oh [ __ ] i'm
not as cool as i thought i was
[Laughter]
somebody knows somebody knows how many
times
okay tila which popular horror film was
inspired by real events that took place
in gainesville florida in the early 90s
i feel like maybe that was scream
which movie is more whack blue velvet or
dead ringers those are both awesome
movies so
that is not a valid question no it
wasn't the salah
the sulaco was the name of the ship that
the aliens that the marines came in an
alien too
that's right how many times does michael
myers show up in the background
of a scene in halloween oh that's a hard
one
in the back well what counts is in the
background like when
jamie lee curtis looks out the window
and then sees him
that's not really in the background
though is it because she's like looking
out and he comes out of the bushes
yeah gadgy uh thank you very much
gadgey3
gave us a super chat wicked idea for a
wednesday stream do it 9am on a sunday
so i don't get this jaked on a school
night
i know well we recorded a show with uh
adam sane from conspira normal last
night yeah
and i've been doing shows all week so we
were drinking and he was drinking it was
a fun show though
yeah i think it was right i think it was
called the narcissus
that's probably that's might have been
because ripley
um believes an audio log of what had
happened and i think she signs off
it might have been the narcissus if i
remember correctly
that sounds right although i i don't
want to say yeah
i got this other game too it says now oh
this is a hard one i don't even know if
i know this one complete the tagline for
maniac cop
you have the right to remain calm
remains of the day remain silent forever
remain dead i'm gonna guess that nope
that's wrong remain silent forever
i haven't seen maniac cop in a long time
uh oh that's easy okay that was that's
an alien one
uh which of the following movies doesn't
exist
bride of chucky bride of frankenstein
bride of candyman bride of reanimator
bride of candy well obviously that's a
really easy that's an easy question
uh the film army of darkness was
released in which of the following years
1992 1995 1997 1987.
i don't know i'm terrible with dates
i am too kind of i
think it was it nope it was 92. okay i
should have gone with my first instinct
main character in the reanimator film
series
that's herbert dr west yeah
how many friday the 13th movies are
there by now oh [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
that is not one of the that's not one of
the choices i think there are ten
wait did okay are they counting freddie
versus thirteen of them it's twelve
twelve okay they wanted to make thirteen
but i don't think what is the stuff
ice cream beer salad or coleslaw
ice cream it's technically not ice cream
it's kind of more like yogurt
yeah but i thought it was kind of more
like frozen cool whip
yeah it was kind of like cool whip yeah
that is a crazy [ __ ] movie [ __ ]
larry cohen uh what's the name of the
character which jamie lee curtis played
of lori strode obviously
uh some of these are easy what's the
name of the third pumpkin head movie
there wasn't there was more it was the
third pumpkin
i didn't know that blood feud ashes to
ashes blood wings or dust to death blood
wings
how did you get on your face for going
down [ __ ] man okay
oh i got it right ashes to ashes what's
the name of the first movie about dr
hannibal lecter red dragon silence of
the land hannibal or manhunter that
would be a man hunter yes it would
come on okay my finger's not working
i don't want to install candy crush
though stop it this app was free so
yeah blood wings blood wigs
what you get when you go down a girl
she's on her period yeah that's what
wings i don't know where they're getting
there so i think that's funny that they
made that one of the choices
yeah oh my god
oh my god i said what was the name of
the surgeon in human centipede
oh what the [ __ ] was that dude i
remember
i remember the name of that crazy german
boot dude the name
of the actor was taught was uh tom six
i think yeah but i can't remember the
name of the character i've only seen
that like one time
i think i liked that movie i i did too
i watched the second one but i only got
like maybe a half hour into it it was
kind of slow i i lost interest
yeah it's you know well although some
people say that
part that the second one is really good
but like i said i had that five
ten twenty minute rule you know what i'm
talking about dj mainac says no pumpkin
head 2
is blood wings no joke no joke oh [ __ ]
okay so that's pretty hilarious that's
ridiculous they had to know what that
was of course they know i mean
even i knew what that was not even a
dude
unless they're from canada which one oh
which one of the following elm street
characters is not a member of dream
warriors
taryn white will stanton alice johnson
or nancy thompson
well wait a minute was nancy was not one
of the dream whoa
[ __ ] this is okay i know taran was
because i remember that name
i'm gonna guess that oh okay alice
johnson that was the correct answer
uh the 1980 film friday the 13th was
directed by who
that would be shawness cunningham very
easy
uh who directed land of the dead
obviously
george a romero that's also very easy
barry cox helen shivers ray bronson is
that his porn name
are they
are the protagonists from which mary and
him cops deep in there
oh my god uh
is that oh [ __ ]
okay i know what you did last summer
that's what it was
what is leatherface's signature weapon
does he even have a signature weapon
well a chainsaw i guess
but he uses other things too who is the
main antagonist
in the grudge franchise
that is sadako no it's kayako sorry
i guess i messed that up that's it
i'm going to put on the ranger he's
going to put on the range ranger patrol
cap
which role didn't roll that [ __ ] which
role did brad dorf play in 1988 child's
play uh chucky obviously
got to get that [ __ ] cocked back off to
the side like that
all right how many oscars did the
exorcist win
i don't know well it was nominated for a
bunch i don't remember if it won any
maybe one maybe two anybody know
uh i'm gonna guess two oh that was
correct all right
i knew it won some it said leave it to
tom make a porn reference
yeah of course oh look how uh okay the
video
is sexual he's a sexual trainer sexual
well you don't have the sexual
tyrannosaur
no hat on yet no not yet that's this is
exactly what this question says you guys
how ash williams calls his shotgun
that's boomstick okay how ash williams
calls his shotgun i just thought that
was very funny
yeah what yeah what does he call it how
he call it
yeah who was phone oh my god
so you have to get this one's like short
because it was free
uh what was what level was that oh but
there's a bunch of levels that holy crap
i didn't realize
it was two uh exorcist one what was the
name of the zombie
who shot rhodes in day of the dead
bub yeah easy
in stephen king's it how did children
originally defeat pennywise
uh wait a minute with golden rings
with holy water with a crucifix or with
silver earrings
i don't remember what this it was the
earrings it
because i knew it wasn't something like
yeah
paris hilton played which character in
the 2005
film house of wax i don't remember the
name of her character
but uh so i'm going to say paige edwards
which was correct because the other
names sounded kind of janky
what is the name of the girl she was
great though she was good in that
no she was great in that uh uh musical
what was it [ __ ] um
repo the genetic repo the genetic opera
yeah the name of the girl that was
murdered in last house on the left
i know that answer but let's see if
anybody else does tila did you see repo
genetic opera
you need to see that one had good music
in there
that wasn't a good question
duh that's a really easy one some of
these are super easy
uh yeah everybody don't know this one
the film prince of darkness was directed
by
who whom john carpenter obviously
that was a weird movie who is the priest
in the exorcism of emily rose ooh
it's either yeah
richard moore that was his name
uh i did not see that movie which
character did ian glenn play in the film
resident evil extinction
i'm not into the resident evil movies
yeah t you'd like that
it's a musical but it's like it's a
gothic industrial musical yeah it's
called repo
repo genetic the genetic paris hilton
plays a plays
one of the roles in there it's it's in a
dystopian future
where you could get genetic you could
get modifications to make you look
beautiful if you paid for them
okay uh if they'd sell them to you on
credit
if you didn't [ __ ] pay your bill they
come and take them back from you so it
might be some [ __ ] like
really cool eyes that you would buy or
like better
just features and um
one of the one of the main characters is
a dude
uh who is a grave robber and he's
looking for
he's he's pulling corpses out of the
ground and abstracting something from
their rotten pituitary glands glands
called xydrate and xylite from xitrate
you can make this drug that will allow
you to feel no
pain from any of these surgeries and
recover very quickly
so everybody wants side rate and it's
just
real poor people or real rich people the
rich people are getting all these damn
genetic modifications and everything
and um it's it's cool you'll like it
it's very very cool kind of like uh kind
of like
kind of like um
what's that other [ __ ] come on i'm
drunk man
it's kind of like it's kind of like
rocky horror but the music is more
contemporary and it's a lot more
hardcore it's like a horror movie
it's really good it's like i like it
yeah honestly um i saw it it's on
um one of the streaming services might
be on hulu
or might be on tubey even and uh so i
put it in the poll a couple times but it
never won
yeah uh but yeah if it's funny still in
uh
goth industrial clubs to this day you
still hear
uh what the hell was the name of that
song
yeah exaggerate something yeah and one
of the repo
repo is talking about repossession one
of the characters as a repo man
if you didn't pay your medical bill he
shows up and cuts those modifications
out of you
while you're alive yeah he's
repossessing yeah and it might be you
bought a [ __ ] badass set of eyeballs
that could do some stuff
it might be that might be that you but
well some of the stuff had special
abilities didn't it
that was inside it uh didn't
i thought some of it worked because when
that one girl blind and she bought some
eyeballs that allowed her to see
a lot better than normal eyes yeah maybe
i haven't seen that movie in so long and
um there's all kinds of
pretty cool and that movie is like it's
not that old
it's pretty old though i mean it's old
it's from
was it from the early 2000s i feel like
it was from
yeah it was big in the goth scene but
the nation what was it called zydrate
anatomy
hydrated anatomy yeah that's a song that
was in it one of the big songs they used
to play in the clubs back
you know [ __ ] guess 10 years ago was
one called xyzrate anatomy and it was
paris hilton did the vocals on
it and it was a good club song it is and
like i said it was it
every now and then still at momento mori
they'll play it and it still packs the
dance floor
yep it's a good yeah
yeah and then one of the characters in
there looks just like our friend andy
the one that was getting her eyeballs
[ __ ] stolen back here you're gonna
get her eyeballs repo the singer
that's right she looks just like andy
that's right she did
yeah we have a friend that looks just
like that yeah who comes to mannequin
sometimes
we've known her for ever tila said can
you imagine getting your new ass repo'ed
yeah you didn't pay for that [ __ ]
stop paying your bills that's like my
[ __ ] step granddad on my [ __ ]
dad's side my dad's step dad
he would bury your ass in his [ __ ]
cemetery and if you didn't
on credit if you didn't pay for it he'd
dig that [ __ ] back up box and all
[ __ ] put it on your porch
how's it mississippi i kind of love that
though they're like hey
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't i mentioned it
in the show before you know
he was he was an ex-con all right and he
was a [ __ ] crook
oh my god i love it and he bought a
piece of land and
and and turned it in to a graveyard for
black people
because in mississippi black people and
white people beckon that era were buried
separately
but he was a [ __ ] crook man and uh
he would sell you the plot and do the
burial and everything on credit
you know [ __ ] he'd give his own
credit you know what didn't involve the
bag
and it was all good unless unless you
stop paying
so he drive down there with his grave
diggers and they were black guys
you know and they'd come up there and go
up to your porches you're going to pay
we want our [ __ ] if not we're gonna
[ __ ] put him right here on this
[ __ ] porch
and they would [ __ ] yeah yeah we'll
get you we'll get you the money because
you got two weeks you know that kind of
stuff
two weeks would pass and the money would
never show up they'd pull up they'd have
a [ __ ] casket
and everything in the back of the truck
they'd be unloading it hold up hold up
hold up hold up
and then he'd give him the money and
then they [ __ ] leave unbeknownst to
them
it was just a casket they had in the
back of the shop
it wasn't one that had the had the loved
one in it
the loved ones they had they had uh you
know because it was all the same casket
they had one of them that looked all
[ __ ]
rusty and rotten and [ __ ] and they had
that on a special occasion to come down
there and put more leverage on you
there's all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that he did that is pretty late
yeah
now that was just part of the game you
know what i mean [ __ ]
they would dicks dig up that down body
yeah well yeah because they resell that
plot
well i mean yeah i guess if you if you
had a lot of foresight
yeah you could bury the bodies real deep
and then you could bury them up
subsequent layers yeah
you know you could bury people on top of
each other it's not like they would care
yeah what would happen though is that
you know over a period of [ __ ]
10 15 years sometimes the relatives of
the
person that was buried were gone you
couldn't find them well that's what i
mean
and then sometimes they hadn't paid but
they didn't care yeah they're just all
right they just
they just they only dealt with people
that were still alive and still around
trying to get more money out of you
grampur's hammer asked what was the name
of the goat in the witch
black philip i think was the goat's name
somebody asked julianne moore versus
jody foster
as clarice starling uh jody foster
although um
julian moore was good too but it was it
was weird seeing that movie like seeing
someone else playing clarice just
because i feel like jody foster like so
kind of defined to that role you know
what i mean that's why it's hard for me
seeing other people playing hannibal
lecter because
although i love manhunter but that came
out before silence of the lambs yeah
somebody said they had trouble [ __ ]
imagining digging the body back up you
don't understand mississippi
you don't understand mississippi yes
they would dig that body it's just like
right but it would just depend it would
depend on how grievous the [ __ ]
situation was
usually they just used a [ __ ] an
empty casket that looked rusty they just
used that
but eventually if you [ __ ] stop
paying yeah they eventually would dig it
up and they would put it up on the porch
yeah now see gram through hammer said
black peter and i was like no it's not
black peter and dj maniac
very rightly said uh no black peter is
the guy that hangs out with norwegian
santa claus that's right
yeah it was black phillip i'm pretty
sure i've seen that movie a couple times
but yeah it was black phillip ed gaine
dug up a bunch yeah he didn't seem to
have a problem
is that the one that comes down the
chimney which is why he's dark didn't we
do a show it was probably
oh god it was probably like our first
christmas special so probably like four
years ago
um yeah black francis the guy from the
pixies
um but yeah so uh we did a show about
that and we talked about
black peter i don't know if is he the
one that comes down the chimney he was
kind of like a krampus type of
dude he didn't he have like a switch and
he'd beat like bad kids or whatever
if you guys um have ever read and
did you get in trouble dressing up like
him they still do it though he's gonna
do it anyway
that's europe that's back in the hockey
motherland back in the hockey by the way
yeah
they'll [ __ ] paint their faces black
and it looks like it
looks like a [ __ ] dude wearing black
face that's not what it is yeah it looks
like some al jolson [ __ ]
yeah that's not what it is though it's
it's a it's a traditional
germanic character called black peter
he's kind of like krampus he's the evil
he's the evil santa claus
basically i just i'm so happy can i say
that krampus has actually started to
make some cultural inroads into the
united states because
i feel like you have santa claus i know
we have all the clasher movies where
santa claus is killing people you know
so that's good
but i feel like you need the evil santa
claus too because there's the whole
thing about naughty and nice santa claus
doesn't really punish people he just
gives you coal
if you're bad right but i like the idea
of like krampus coming in like taking
you away and like putting you in a bag
and
beating the [ __ ] out of you and taking
you to hell or whatever it is badger
says not anymore
um it says they get in trouble for doing
that but i think it depends on what
country you're in
i think you probably up in [ __ ]
norway and [ __ ] where these would they
have that i think they still do that
maybe i've seen pictures of it from
parades but that might be a few years
back
and i don't think is it is it skin black
or is he black because he came down to
chimney
i don't know i don't remember exactly
what the mythology
is i was kind of under the under the
impression i mean it was because he was
coming down a chimney i'm kind of sure
i was going to say if you guys have ever
read any of the hilarious
essays by david sedaris
he wrote one i think the title of it was
six to eight black men
and he was talking about weird uh
christmas traditions in other parts
of the world and that was one i don't
know if he was talking about black peter
specifically but
i think he was talking about one where
santa's sleigh was pulled by 68 black
men or he had six to eight black men
like in his entourage or something like
that he says i've seen
african-americans get really like say
what when they see black peter in the
netherlands
but she's also sitting with afros so it
might be yeah see that's what i might be
i think it was i think that was the
original it might just be he's black
yeah okay but and they want to dress up
like that
and you know take it take
the the whole the whole it's not it look
it's not [ __ ] um like al jolson and
[ __ ]
okay that was that was a hollywood thing
that's not what they're talking about
what do they call it minstrel shows
where where black impersonators
that's like amos and andy texas not what
it is they're trying to dress up
like a character from a story they have
to be black
now what's funny is that the japanese do
that [ __ ] with impunity
they dress up like black people and go
to [ __ ] rap clubs
they're the only black people there
they're japanese people
with [ __ ] dark makeup on and frozen
[Laughter]
you know they love that music and they
they're
they like they like that culture what
they see
from at least in music videos you know
but you can't take that
you can't take that [ __ ] the same way
you know it's like
it's like a like a menstrual shell
because they do the same [ __ ] with white
people
they'll deny it over and over again but
no they dress up as white people
all the time they'll [ __ ] change
their hair color they'll put in blue
contacts they'll
get eyelid surgery to kind of have round
eyes or you know get rid of the eye
folds and
uh they just like how white people look
and they they're white you know
they're white impersonators in japan
no way i hate to say it but that's
exactly what they're white impersonators
well i didn't die but that's what it is
well i mean i guess
if you grow up somewhere i mean japan is
not as homogeneous as it used to be
but i guess if you grow up in a culture
where everybody is the same race
yeah everyone's the same race yeah then
anything
else is going to be like exotic yeah and
they're not in danger of insulting
anybody
because it's everybody's japanese
they're not gonna run into white people
do you remember that there i don't know
if it's still around but they did have
that kind of subculture of all those
japanese
guys that dressed up like elvis they had
like the big
duck ass hairdos and you know the big
pompadours and [ __ ]
yeah um but yeah oh yeah
okay so somebody yeah it was me talk
pretty one day i think that was where
that essay was which i think i
have on my bookshelf somewhere which i
think i borrowed from my friend and
never gave back so
sorry i just forgot that i had it uh
tom there are black norwegians yeah but
we're talking about black we're talking
about black peter
yeah anything to do with black
norwegians yeah um
[Music]
japanese game shows they're talking
about japanese culture is hilarious
it's yeah it's just i don't know they
they just have so much [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] and i know some of this stuff is
probably like exaggerated like the
schoolgirl
youth girl schoolgirl panties uh vending
machines and [ __ ] like that
you know i don't know if that's a real
thing but
yeah camp guy said not sure if that's
the book or not it might be because
that's i have that book and i remember
reading that essay
but i've checked some of his other ones
out of the library too so i don't
remember which one it was
he's saying the japanese do the black
girl look uh the
the cola girl look they like the look so
yeah they'll do the black girl look
they'll do the white girl look they'll
like i said it's looks they don't have
there's no
there's no concept of cultural
appropriation or anything like that it's
not insulting to them it's just oh i
like that look they want to look like
that there's
right there's no cultural message to
them because
they don't have the same color they
don't have it and then another thing
that's funny about you know living in
korea
you know i lived in korea for a year and
japan is different
but the koreans and japanese don't get
along but
it's that same fish bowl it's just a
different fish bowl but it's a fish bowl
type country
uh it's just them and it's made for
japanese and korean men
really that's what that's what the
countries are made for it keeps
everybody else out
and they just kind of i don't know man
they just kind of
they see foreigners and foreign culture
is just
kind of like an exotic oddity and they
want to emulate that
but there's no reality in it for them
it's something that's distant kind of a
fantasy
they'll see like they'll see goth people
or punk rockers or
broccobillies or hip-hop and they
they don't understand that those are
very different cultures they don't
have a really a concept of of subculture
they just see those as styles and they
adopt them and it becomes kind of like a
it's very superficial if you know what
i'm talking about like yeah
well it just looks it doesn't have
anything to do with behavior i mean yeah
for an
example let's talk about the goth lolita
subculture which actually i really
really like the
look of that i mean they have like a
regular lolita subculture which is
basically like young women dressing up
in
kind of victorian little girl looking
stuff uh but they have a goth lolita
version of that or
you know that was like real big back in
the 90s i guess
um and i guess you can still get clothes
like that nowadays but the interesting
thing about that subculture is that it's
all about the clothes
yeah it's they don't listen to goth
music really yeah so they don't have i
don't even know
music or culture and they would be
horrified by
real goth culture that that would be
totally unacceptable to them
a lot of it would have to do because
just just on very superficial reasons
one
goths have tattoos yeah they can't do
that
yeah and and the idea that you're kind
of like that all the time and it's like
it's like a subculture almost kind of
like a tribe or a subdivision
of kind of like a white culture
even though [ __ ] we know so many black
gods it's not even funny you know i mean
it it's it's kind of taking root in
people outside you know outside the
caucasian race
uh lots of lots of latinos and latins
you know they just mix right in so
it's but it started off as something
very english really
yeah and i feel like i mean and i feel
like some people maybe i don't know
about nowadays but i
i think for a long time they were still
the perception
that goth was a very white um you know
middle class
yeah type of because it was generally
like you know goths were very educated
they were really into art and literature
and all that
i don't know where you were depending on
where you were i think maybe that was
more of a uk thing than an american
thing maybe because a lot of those kids
were also punk rockers they were [ __ ]
from the hood basically and yeah here's
something else though england was very
different
and you had black people
in the goth scene and then the punk rock
scene in england and you didn't have
that in the united states there was a
big difference
not until more recently much recently
yeah that was very recent
because yeah punk rockers listen to ska
you know there wasn't enough [ __ ] pop
to listen to so they listened to scott
they wouldn't play anything else where
they're gonna they're gonna play allen
parsons project
they're gonna play [ __ ] pink floyd on
the [ __ ] on the jukebox no
they're gonna put [ __ ] ska because
that's that's not
[ __ ] pink floyd yeah i mean they
don't want to prog rock you know
yeah that's what they like i said that's
what they were rebelling against
and they're hanging out in the hood
basically you know
and you got jamaicans in there and
they're dating each other and
some people are already kind of mixed
and they're in this hanging out with
[ __ ]
young susie sue and sex pistols and
billy idol you know and they're all in
there
blowing each other getting each other
hand jobs
british girls were great especially the
ones that were older than him
at that time because he was like 15 or
16. he was cute enough to get a hand job
from all these [ __ ]
punk rock girls yeah because i feel like
punk rock
yeah i mean but like i said not so much
now but
back in the day when it kind of first
started i feel like punk rock was more
working class yeah and goth was a little
bit more middle class
right that was kind of like the slightly
more refined version but that [ __ ]
didn't come over to the united states in
the [ __ ] late 70s in the early 80s it
came over only like
around l.a they were listening to kroq
radio station
and you had some of the very early duran
duran and
very early susie started to come in
through those area areas
and it was only the white kids that were
listening to that it took a lot longer
for black
i mean [ __ ] peop about it think about
the 80s and the 90s you know i knew
i [ __ ] was hanging out black dudes
they would refuse to listen to metal
just refused to listen to it it wasn't
until it was very recently that you
started seeing and
they were kind of younger than us
yeah the one you know now will's an
exception
he's what three years older than me he
was in that shift yeah he's in his 50s
he's in his he's in his no he of course
i mean yeah he's in his midfield
his mid-50s yeah and he was always into
that
yeah so but but you know will was
military wills it was a oddball
yeah you know so that coming up in the
clubs here there was only
usually only one or two black people
yeah that
was at the golf clubs yeah at the golf
club there was into that
now it's more now you'd see like six
it's yeah more regular than others i
feel like it's not odd now
it's not as obvious i feel like in the
80s it would have been more odd i don't
i don't think
anybody would have said much of anything
about it right
but it was more unusual to see back then
especially in the south
yeah big time especially in the south
yeah you didn't it's like i knew a
couple but
it was yeah it was very unusual don't
trip over your sexual tyrannosaur
[Laughter]
it's just i don't know it's i yeah
i feel like i was gonna say something i
kind of it just went right out of my
head i don't remember what it was
but yeah i do kind of feel like
uh i don't know i i guess because i grew
you know the place i grew up i grew up
in daytona beach which was kind of
you know i i so i grew up in a more
working class or more poor kind of
thing and i was kind of i was rolling a
punk and then i was really into goth so
i kind of
and the thing about it was that before
it went more
mainstream which didn't really happen
until the early 90s
um it would you kind of like everybody
that was
into weird [ __ ] um no matter what it was
you kind of just all hung out together
even if you didn't like the same [ __ ]
necessarily
there was a like a lot more crossover
you know
i was gonna say too when i was talking
about um gothic lolita and about
you know just it being about fashion and
not so much about the music or the
culture behind it um once
once goth went mainstream like i said a
pr it was kind of in the 90s because i
feel like after
alternative music kind of mainstreamed
in
you know 1990 1991 whatever it was
and everyone kind of got into that got
hip to it
i feel like a lot of kids that maybe
grew up in the 90s
because this is something we used to
like grouse about all the time
you'd get these kids like coming into
the scene and they just liked the look
but they didn't really know anything
about the music they didn't really know
anything about
particularly like the older music goth
music or anything like that they kind of
sometimes like i'd go into like hot
topic or some [ __ ] like that like in the
90s and the music they were playing was
just like i was like what the [ __ ] is
this crap
it just sounded like well so to me it
just sounded like pop punk
yeah you know what i mean which you know
it's not terrible i like some of that
[ __ ]
you know i i liked green day kind of
i saw them live back in the day before
dookie came out after that came out and
they got [ __ ] huge
i liked their first album but um
you know but i feel like a lot of them
were into pop punk which just was
confusing for me you know what i'm
saying yeah it's just
it's changed in recent years you know i
mean [ __ ]
yeah and dj maniacs talking about cyber
gods yeah that that was really a trend i
couldn't
get down with because i remember when um
also in the early 90s when kind of rave
culture went a little more mainstream
particularly like with all the mad
chester
type stuff and you know everyone was on
ecstasy and wearing [ __ ]
yeah pacifiers around their necks and
[ __ ] like that and
i just couldn't hang with that yeah some
of the music was okay but i didn't
there's there's a uh another channel
here on youtube
called obscura undead and
uh one of the vj's on there is uh
dj mouse who's a friend of ours she's
been over here and everything
yeah she's from tampa she's from tampa
jenny does a lot of her promotional
materials
actually or actually the promotional
interior is for the clubs that she works
at it's not really her
materials right yeah and and i made
shirts for
yeah i do i do a lot of the communion
after dark yeah
uh their radio show like when they do
like weekly and they have guest djs and
stuff i usually do
yeah their little facebook i'm gonna
show you some stuff show you dj mouse
she's rad i love her yeah she's real
cool
i think he's still married didn't she
yeah as far as i know yeah she got
married not too but well
yeah i was going to say it wasn't that
long ago but maybe it was
maybe time's like passing around time
goes by i actually i talked to
michael from a starry night earlier
today on the phone
and they are doing a show at will's pub
in july it's not we can't really see her
but that
yeah she's awesome i love her
yeah i love her the channel's called
obscura she's a sweetheart
yeah yeah it's her
and um dj azzy is the other girl
but yeah um but also i was going to say
something else
oh he was asking me too he's like
he said to me today on the phone he's
like what was that place
that little bar because he was asking me
about mannequins because he's never been
there because it hasn't been there that
long
and he's like what's that place that was
in orlando where we met
and i was like oh my god that was like
so long ago and for a second he was like
because he was like oh there was a
tattoo shop in there and for a second i
thought stigma
which isn't there anymore because that
was like had the tattoo shop and then
there was like kind of a
goth bar on the other side but no he was
talking about the grotto
is what he was talking about remember
that place yeah it had been a long time
that's been a long time since i was
going because i was like oh yeah that
had a tattoo studio in the front too
didn't it i forgot i totally forgot
about that
it's it's really sad i really wish that
place had been successful but you know
yeah yeah
that's her yeah sherry mouse yeah see if
i got another cool picture
look she's doing that
yeah there you go there you go yeah
she's super cute
yeah yeah gadgey3 said stone roses yeah
i love the stone roses i love
um in spiral carpets wasn't a big fan
because i remember happy mondays were
real big back then and i just i don't
know i couldn't get down with that
but man what was that movie that was
like half about joy division and half
about happy mondays
that had [ __ ] steve coogan in it what
the [ __ ] the name of that movie
god damn it 24 hour party people
which is a great [ __ ] movie if you
haven't seen it um
i really i liked the happy mondays part
of it but
i feel like i had kind of lost interest
in
a lot of the way that the club scene was
going at that
point because i kind of feel like this
was something i complained about a lot
in the 90s
um was that i feel like goth music
started going more toward
industrial you know what i mean um
you know in synth pop and stuff like
that which is fine i liked some of it
but i don't know i've i've always been
more like a death rock
post punk kind of person um i like some
industrial i like some
synth pop you know i like vnv nation
they're fine i like mesh
um you know apoc uh what do you call
them
berserk whatever the [ __ ] their
name is they're pretty good um but it's
not like my favorite it's nothing i
would buy
you know what i'm saying covenant or
good
it's just i don't know a lot of that
music is good it just it kind of sounds
kind of generic to me i guess but you
know i really like
and one i really like dossier
um you know they're pretty rad but
i don't know just in general if i'm
gonna like anything that's new it's
gonna be more
post-punky sounding or death rocky
sounding
buzz box love is the slug oh my god i
remember that [ __ ] record
did i like oasis
they had a couple good songs i liked
some other [ __ ] like i kind of i like
pulp
they're pretty good um oasis i wasn't a
i wasn't a huge
fan dj maniac said i heard late era
sisters of mercy described as big dumb
rock music
yeah yeah they did kind of go like yeah
yeah probably
i think after vision thing oh
rap yeah i liked vision thing but
you know honestly there was a couple
songs on there that i would always skip
you know what i mean i liked detonation
boulevard i liked
uh when you don't see me it didn't age
as well as first and last and always
though it just got
he was going more like la metal it was
la metal with a german backup band
yeah he had like andreas broom in there
and
after that i was just kind of like man
because you know
eldritch has always been he's always
kind of been a douche right
yeah he's a [ __ ] dude i'm being
diplomatic he's kind of a douche
um maybe he's not like that anymore but
i don't know i i kind of doubt that well
he's just one of those like superior
well actually [ __ ] and yeah he
just thought he was smarter than
everybody else and
i'm so much cooler than everybody else
he just always gave off that vibe which
always annoys me
so you know the first record is awesome
first and last and always i mean
technically that's like i guess that's
their first full-length album they did
like a bunch of [ __ ] before they did eps
before they did eps and singles and [ __ ]
like that i mean alice is one of the
best [ __ ] goth songs ever
yeah it's a single and it's a single
yeah but reptile house [ __ ] had some
good stuff on it yeah
noise though all that kind of [ __ ] i
have to say one of my favorite scissors
of mercy songs is their cover
of emma that hot chocolate dog
that oh and yeah their cover of gimme
shelter is really yeah real good so they
had some they had some good [ __ ] it was
going well
until he pissed the band off and they
left and then they became the mission
and also known as the mission uk yeah
and the mission in mission uk are good
they're pretty good although they sound
to me they sound like a slightly gothier
you too
yeah and i was never a big youtube fan i
like old youtube
like the boy album i like pretty much i
liked everything up to joshua tree like
i like joshua tree but then after that
they got too big they got too poppy they
got tail which is kind of early mission
was good though you know
uh that album that had dancing barefoot
on it yeah yeah i'm dancing
barefoot waiting for the spin
strange music drags me in
you know that i think my favorite makes
me feel like heroine or some weird yeah
how does that go i can't remember my
probably my favorite mission song
is wasteland i really like that song
but and that was on like a lot of goth
compilations and stuff back in the day
but as a whole i don't remember i don't
think i ever bought a whole entire
mission uk album i know that i'm
thinking about
medicine i had like three of them yeah
god's own medicine
and then i liked them but not enough to
buy a whole album worth
yeah like i just kind of collected my
favorite you know
god's own you know if you guys know what
god's own medicine is god's own medicine
is morphine
okay they were they were talked about
that kind of [ __ ] a lot i think
they were on that [ __ ] but god's own
medicine was kind of like a
a real dark goth rock
u2 album yeah it aged well though it
sounds like bono singing
but it sounds like it doesn't sound like
but it sounds kind of like sisters of
mercy
early sisters of mercy uh because it's
that same band yeah it was good
yeah it's good it aged well and if you
like well i was going to say if you like
you too but also um
the dude wait he was related to somebody
he was a cousin of somebody that was in
you too that formed
the virgin prunes yeah yeah virgin
prunes now i love the virgin person
virgin prunes was really good
um they had a lot of good [ __ ] and then
there was also
uh
what was that what was that [ __ ] the
tier garden
i really liked the tears yeah i liked it
as well i have one of their cds around
here somewhere
and then how old i am i still got these
i used to have cassettes but then i
threw them all out
yeah you know uh no need for me says i'm
a music fanatic of sorta yeah me too
um i don't collect it as much as i used
to
but i still have i still have all my old
cds
you know grampur's hammer said you two
played in a bar in east lansing named
dooley's in 1982.
[Laughter]
i was i still you know what if they
still if they play like new year's day
or some [ __ ] like at the club i'm still
i'm down with that
early youtube is great because i still
enjoy the album and wore out the world
yeah
good and i actually like some of the
stuff off joshua tree like bullet in the
blue sky
yeah see i like that that's a good album
yeah that's a real good album especially
the b-side stuff the rest of it just got
played to death
like you know um with or without you
played to death that's a great song but
they did play
and i think that was kind of the problem
a lot of the issue i have
like okay for example here's something
that i was just thinking of today
because i was listening to pandora like
i was walking
and i have a post punk station i have an
80s alternative station i have like all
this other kind of [ __ ]
and they play um they played love and
rockets and i love
loving rockets but i swear to god if i
never hear so alive again
it'll be too [ __ ] soon yeah just
because i feel like that was the only
song
because it that song got [ __ ] huge
and that was like their [ __ ] fourth
album or something
that was their fourth album that that
was on they're like the three before
that were like
there's a lot of good reason they just
got played to death i mean i can't
listen i can't listen to anything off
the number of the beast album from iron
maiden
yeah the only one i can listen to would
be like hallowed be thy name or maybe
gang land but
even gang lands not even that good it's
just everything on that
that whole album was alma filler almost
from my point of view
yeah just because everything was real
catchy and
overplayed it's and it's sad because
i mean i love 80s [ __ ] still but
it does really seem like and i kind of
run into this a little bit with my
pandora one like on my 80s alternative
station
uh it actually has a uh uh you know a
thing where you can put deep cuts on
there
which is actually like much better
because that's like playing some old
like [ __ ] echo in the bunnyman album
tracks that i haven't heard for like a
million years and that's awesome
but i i don't know i just i feel like
bands okay so let's talk about like the
cure
right yeah i loved the cure since the
very early 1980s like i
i really like their old old like po like
post punk
punk rock type [ __ ] like they're really
early [ __ ] and then when
disintegration came out in 1990 and
everybody and their mom
was into fascination street which i
think is probably
their worst song i mean i'm not gonna
say that's definitively their worst song
it's just it was [ __ ] everywhere it's
just kind of like susie and the banshees
and kissed them for me yeah was
everywhere was everywhere and i didn't
have them though
it is but they it just that song got
played so much and i think a lot of
people that's the only susan the banshee
song they know all that stuff she did
with the creatures was great
the creatures were so [ __ ] good yeah
i mean
i don't know i it's so i do kind of feel
like
what because we you know we would go to
eye bar pretty much every
weekend like every saturday and they did
yeah and they did
you know they do 80s on saturday night
they still do
and it depends on who's djing but i do
kind of feel like i know that they have
to kind of go with
you know whoever's dancing and if it's
like filling up the dance floor and
everybody wants to dance to [ __ ] they
know i get that
um but i do kind of wish sometimes that
they would play
um songs that weren't as well known you
know what i mean because i do kind of
feel like
you know do we really need to hear that
same erasure song
like a little respect do we really need
to hear that again um
do we really need to hear and it you
know as much as i love like the smiths
for example it's like they really don't
need to play panic every week it's like
play a different one they had a million
good songs and you know the same thing
with
you know like echoing the bunnymen i
love the cutter but
play a different one i'm just saying
um it i don't know so it just gets to a
point where
but then again though there are some
songs from that era
that honestly that i can just hear over
and over again and i don't get tired of
like blue monday i could listen to that
song every day and just be totally i
just
for whatever reason i just never get
sick of that song and same was like
psychedelic furs love
my way they played the [ __ ] out of that
and [ __ ] i first heard that on mtv like
back in [ __ ] 1982 when it came out
and i bought the album
and um thank you because man i love the
psychology furs
but that's another song i kind of never
get sick of it
um same with modern english i melt with
you
although i will say that the album that
that was on
which is called after the snow i bought
that on vinyl in 1982 when it came out
and um
i think because i had heard i melt with
you in the movie
valley girl and i really dug that
and but that whole album i mean i melt
with you is still a good song
but that whole album is really really
good and i feel like
it doesn't get a lot of love you know
what i mean it's almost like a kind of a
gothy sounding
album i think and that's the best known
song on it and that's
pretty much the only modern english song
that people know like nowadays
but that whole album is like fantastic i
had a couple of their albums after that
and they weren't as good as that one but
i still remember the song ink and paper
which i think came out a few years after
and that was good but i don't remember a
lot of their output after that
but i don't know i just
like i said i know that people want to
hear [ __ ] that's familiar
when they're at the club and ibarr
kind of caters to everybody
like just everybody kind of ends up
there so
they kind of have to play more familiar
songs because
you know not everybody there is like
some big 80s music connoisseur so i get
that
but sometimes i do kind of wish they
would switch it up a little bit
it's why i always get super excited if
he like throws on some
wild card like the cramps or something
like that i always get super excited he
always
although if he plays the cramps he
always always always plays what's inside
a girl
every single time which is fine because
i love that song
but i was like they also had a bunch of
other good ones that they never really
play
but every now and then he'll throw on
something like crazy it's almost time to
[ __ ]
cheat that goddamn hat oh it's sexual
tyrannosaur time and that's a rainstorm
cap
no need for me says depeche mode was
always the go-to stuff when i got to
make out with goth chicks
yeah the patch mode was another band
that i loved them in the 80s
um some great reward is a [ __ ]
fantastic album black celebration easily
my favorite depate album
um after violator which came out in 1990
and i saw them live at the [ __ ]
orlando arena which isn't even called
that anymore
i saw them live with uh nitsureb opening
but after violator came out i was kind
of like yeah i don't really feel the
need to buy any more depeche mode albums
i still hear like some of the newer [ __ ]
and i like it but
one actually i had one of their albums
that was later i think was called ultra
and i can't remember what year that came
out but that one was pretty good but it
wasn't like super memorable like their
old [ __ ] was
and i don't know if it was just because
the songs were better on the old ones or
just because i got older
you know what i'm saying it's kind of
hard to say and i liked some of uh dave
gahan's solo [ __ ] as well
oh and also martin gore did solo stuff
too he did a couple
albums of covers which were actually
really good i think they're called
counterfeit
they were eps maybe i think they only
had seven or eight songs on them i've
had i had the first one and i think he
did a second one
although i will say martin gore did a
cover
of nick cave's lover man and
i didn't love it i didn't love it
because the nick cave version like much
of nick cave songs
was like real dirty you know what i mean
like just the sound of it and i feel
like when martin gore did it he kind of
like cleaned it up and made it kind of
depeche moody which i i just don't think
that worked very well for that
particular song
but props to martin gorffer covering it
at cave song because that's pretty red
but i just i didn't like his version of
it
you know what i'm saying yeah i put i
put um
i put sherry mouse's channel in the uh
in the conversation there's a link there
dj maniac said metallica covered lover
man too and it's trash i agree
i mean if you're gonna listen to lover
man just listen to the [ __ ] original
one
plus if you i'm sure you can find the
video on youtube the video is [ __ ]
awesome because
i think lover man is the one where they
got a hypnotist
in that hypnotized to the whole band and
it's almost kind of like the video has
like a hypnosis theme to it
and they hypnotize them i have
uh i have the nick cave like video
compilation and it's awesome because it
has him and like blix and bargeld and
they're talking in the middle
about uh about filming the videos like
with the experience there's like little
interview snippets with them
and he said that the hypnotist told them
before they shot that video he admits
he hypnotized all of them and said um
you're going to give like the best
performance of your life
right because they had like all the
weird creepy
like hypnosis stuff where they were all
like you know sitting there like falling
asleep with the [ __ ] like in front of
their eyes and stuff
and then they cut it with like a live
performance and everybody does indeed
seem like they're just [ __ ] like
going ape [ __ ] like on the thing and
it's like really awesome that's probably
my favorite nick cave video i don't know
but another oh while i'm talking about
that the video for
the weeping song which if you've seen it
is basically just nick cave and blix of
bargail
in a boat like on a ocean that's made
out of
like hefty bags or whatever and um i
think that cave says before they did
that
he's like well he's like this is the
this is an example
of how not to make a video he says first
thing
don't give me the money he's like
because
i think that the money was spent on
other things
heroin he means heroin they gave him
money to make the video and he spent it
on heroin
so then they had to do it like on the
cheap
which just i don't know that just made
me laugh so much it's still a good video
though
but yeah they did make an ocean at a
hefty bag it still looks pretty cool it
doesn't look like as cheesy as that
implies
i don't think was it a video what video
was yeah the weeping song
i didn't see it yeah then it came song
if that was from
1990 if that was off the good side
i think that came out in 1990 or 1991
maybe
gee i put a link to that channel you
were looking for in case in case you
couldn't find it
that's that's that's obscure undead
that's that's sherry's channel
yeah it's a good [ __ ] that's a really
good good channel they do
they'll play some music and uh what's
cool is that uh
when they're playing music they'll put
pictures of [ __ ] goth hotties up
there and it's all people we know
that's all that's all people from the
castle yeah that's what their name is
all people from the castle and it's all
people
you know from uh orlando scene and
you know it's a it's uh we're not in it
but it's like all the dancer girls yeah
like what's her name from the from that
store that's over there yeah
she's but god man she's been dancing at
that club for forever yeah since i've
been going
she does all kinds of stuff what was her
name again um [ __ ] i'm too drunk
we used to run into her all the time
yeah we saw her at the start
or convention
dj maniac says see i knew blixa mainly
from einstein's i know about
yeah i did as well uh but yeah he was
also in the bad seas although he kind of
he took off after because he was like
yeah you guys are doing some [ __ ] like
that
he didn't really want to do anymore i
guess although i
you know i liked the new nick cave stuff
but i could see how like blixa probably
didn't want to go in that direction
i will say as much as i love um
einstein's annoying mountains like
old like noise [ __ ] their album i think
it came out in 2004
perpetua mobile uh which was actually
kind of a more
i'm not gonna say it was mainstream but
it was like a lot more mellow
so you know it's mellow for them i
actually really really love that record
i used to play the [ __ ] out of that when
it first came out
um no need for me too says suicide girls
is something i enjoy
though i don't know if there's still a
thing um
yeah are they still around the suicide
girls i don't know because
that was their heyday yeah their heyday
was kind of in the 90s i kind of feel
like right
i think so i don't even know if that's
around anymore i mean
it probably is there's still
uh i'm sure there's still a market for
that
but you know um
what was the other girl that used to
dance up there
friend of ours she's the one that has
the damn eye patch on all the time
yeah i know um [ __ ] she just posted some
cool [ __ ] the other day i was going to
show them
that other girls name is uh sheena right
yeah sheena shane is one of them i just
no i got her on facebook yeah she's kick
ass i was
like i said i used to see her all the
time when i went to the castle back in
yeah here she goes the late 90s early
2000s
she runs like a goth store like a goth
closing clothing store with her mom
because her mom used to go to the castle
too her mom's rad yeah
but uh yeah that was that was a fun time
sheena always had like she had the best
[ __ ] outfits yeah she had a different
one that girl
knows every single time she had a
different [ __ ] outfit
i don't even know where she got all this
[ __ ] well i guess because they run a
store that's why so she could just
borrow [ __ ] from the store
trying to find a fantastic picture i
just remember back in the old days
because the castle
we haven't been there in a few years but
back in the old days
you know the castle is kind of it's big
and it's like two stories
and then down this one little hall
there's the bathrooms
which are you know it's nominally says
men and ladies on it but nobody cares
they're
the doors are open you just go in and
whatever and you would always see
the girls like getting ready like before
their first
they'd be in there putting their makeup
on and [ __ ] like that that's sheena yeah
yeah yeah she's awesome
and that's a fairly recent picture i
think and she's probably alright she's
got to be
yeah she's our age you wouldn't know you
wouldn't know that these people are all
40s and 50s by looking at it's another
picture
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think last time we
saw her
at the last
horror convention we were at because she
was there
she had a booth with her mom like for
the store
that they that they have they have a
store over there like in a strip mall or
whatever the [ __ ] the name of that
place
[ __ ] i've been there i just can't
remember the name of it
my memory's starting to go too it's all
that liquor yeah it's pickling my brain
but yeah she always looked fantastic
she's always her outfit was like always
perfect yeah
and she had a different and she did
something different like every single
time and i think she dances there
i don't know how many nights she does
now but she used to do at least two or
three nights a week oh [ __ ]
because the castle had these like raised
platforms
yeah they always had these big raised
platforms
and um they'd usually have like three
that's a castle
yeah yeah she's dancing up on a box yeah
they have like those boxes
they'd always usually have either three
girls or two girls and a guy or
something like that so there'd always be
somebody up there dancing for like
several songs
and then they'd come down and take a
break they're the kids
yeah she goes all out yeah they're
expensive outfits
she makes a lot of that she's also she's
got some kind of retail store too
yeah like i said her and her mom like
yeah i'm assuming it's still open
yeah we went there remember we went to
the vampire oh remember this outfit what
was it
the wings yeah yeah i remember that yeah
i remember that
yeah yeah she's red she's super nice
um yeah we went to that store the last
time we went to the vampire ball with
jenna dimitri and we went to the store
because we were staying in a hotel over
there and we went to the store like the
afternoon before
to see if they had anything that we
could wear
i mean we had [ __ ] to wear but we were
just looking for extra [ __ ] or better
[ __ ] to wear
but you know i'm trying to remember the
other one that used to used to dance
with her
she was from here remember i used to see
her all the time
little bitty thing man what was her we
did the poster with her
olivia olivia that's right oh man i just
saw it was just
yesterday let me see if i can find
because i think she's i think she's on
my instagram he posted something
yesterday
yeah fantastic yeah it was with the eye
patches yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna try to that's what i was just
thinking of i was like oh i just saw
that picture you see i'm like oh my god
it's olivia i haven't seen her forever
yeah
i don't think she doesn't live here
anymore does she does she move away she
moved away i haven't seen her out
like a million years all right hold on i
found it
yeah where's it at i'm gonna try to full
screen it
yeah that's it that's it
oh it's a video it's moving yes video
yeah oh [ __ ] sorry she [ __ ]
everything out yeah [ __ ] in here
[Laughter]
you you and your sexual tyrannosauruses
tiny arms
[Laughter]
yeah maybe you should rethink trying to
do something
hold on trying to find some cool
pictures of her
sleeves and cheese is teasing us you
guys are satan worshippers wearing all
that black and chips yeah
yeah it's looking funny i kind of missed
well i don't know i was going to say i
kind of missed it i've been called
haven't
haven't been called a satan worshiper in
freaking forever
20 30 years 80s yeah when nobody knew
what goth was
yeah where i grew up where i grew up
people didn't even know who the [ __ ]
cure was that's how [ __ ]
backwards that [ __ ] was that's what
olivia looks like without anything on
yeah okay yeah she's pretty cute
yeah i did a long time ago i did a
momentum poster with her on it
trying to get a good picture of her
oh yeah here's her [ __ ] totally
done that
in her little look at the bonnie or
earth it's a little bunny or
clown outfits and stuff
yeah see i need more money so i can have
yeah we haven't liked it in a long time
fantastic outfits like that
we haven't well that's why i'm so
excited about my bride of frankenstein
yeah
which i'll probably have to put on
before we do the show on friday night
which is about alienware nose by the way
yeah um because we gotta go to the
halfway to halloween party afterwards oh
remember the little
ghoul gargoyle things and she's little
trolls
yeah like her little pointy ears outfits
yeah she was rolling to like yeah
looking like a jim henson character yeah
but it suited her because she goes
little she's yeah she's trying to tiny
tiny little bitty girl she's
maybe 411. she looks like a gelfling
yeah
[Laughter]
and she like impersonates sucking little
japanese rockstar
guys she she she goes in drag
and he's a little dressed up like a
japanese rock star boy yeah there you go
yeah [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
i was gonna say oh i just found out
yesterday
that the halfway to halloween party is
going to be dj'd
by paul and tina vain yeah venue 13.
i know i didn't we're going i don't have
to talk to him
[Laughter]
well i think that was the last minute
well tina told me today she messaged me
earlier
did she and she said i guess they're
going to start
doing venue 13 there semi-regularly
there
okay which that actually makes sense
because like i said they've been
trying to find a venue they do eye bar
once a year and it's always like a big
huge blowout because paul vayne
used to dj at um what do you [ __ ]
call it visage
which is like the quintessential if
you're old you remember you know exactly
what that is yeah it's like the cbgb's
of orlando yeah
kind of well i guess eyebar is kind of
more yeah you have that [ __ ] on the news
yeah i mean but visage i mean [ __ ] man i
saw christian death there back in the
day
i saw you know what i mean i saw so many
[ __ ] i saw peter murphy there like
back in the day
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so
everybody that grew up here knows visage
and paul vane used to dj there
so he's still famous enough in the scene
that he can
that him and his wife come to ibar and
he dj's once a year at ibar it's usually
around christmas time
and that place gets [ __ ] heaving
there's just like a zillion [ __ ]
people in there
i think we the last time we went to that
which was maybe a year or two ago
um because it wasn't this past christmas
i think it was the christmas before and
it was so [ __ ] packed you couldn't
even [ __ ] walk in
there like you were just going like that
like trying to get to the bar and
and i bar is enormous so there was just
like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people in there so they still get that
but you know like i said when we were
kind of first
going out in you know the mid to late
2000s
they you know they had venue 13 and they
would do it usually every friday
and but they had to keep moving venues
because you know would be like a year or
two at one place and then that place
would close
or it would turn into a different kind
of club or whatever so they had to move
someplace else
and then after a while they couldn't
really find a good venue anymore
so they were just like [ __ ] it we're
retiring and we'll just come out once a
year and do the eye bar thing
but i guess i mean they've been wanting
to find a venue where they can come out
every friday
and like i said since mannequins now
does they do what they call black
fridays which
is you know gotham industrial every
friday
so i guess they've been talking to big
tom about
coming back and doing it and big tom of
course would be all about that because
he's he's been in the scene forever as
well he's like an old club guy from back
in the day
i wouldn't have done that on a regular
basis but hey that's his that's
that's true i don't know i don't know if
they're going to do it every week it
might just be like once a month or once
every year that's how i would run
several months
once a month because it's more like a
special occasion okay and yeah
and that will burn out pretty quickly
and only it's only a matter of time
before that burn that out because
that that [ __ ] always burns out
that's the past you gotta leave the past
in the past you have it back on special
occasions but you can't run it too long
because that
that particular scene that particular
clientele is our age
they're older people a lot of them they
only they won't come out that much
well yeah we're the last of the [ __ ]
old people us and the [ __ ]
running the [ __ ] well and there's a
handful
of other people that are sold there but
they're running a handful of other
people
do [ __ ] for a living in this stuff you
know i mean once you're
in your 40s and 50s if you don't really
work in that industry you're not going
to be regular
well yeah you know i'm old i got jobs i
got kids everything i got
right you know and it's like i can't go
out all the time anymore and it's like
you know it happens to everybody
um we're kind of yeah well we're kind of
in a position where
i mean we work at home yeah so we can go
out and get [ __ ] up and it's like it's
okay
and we're and we're in the new creative
industry we make [ __ ]
we're making stuff and producing stuff
that they need
shirts and graphics and we have
youtube shows and [ __ ] it
we're doing what the what old industries
used to do that are gone now
yeah because it's all been disseminated
down at the local level because the
technology's there now
we're the future it's just going to get
even more and more like this
they're going to get younger and younger
one of the things about the club
industry
and the club scene is that you can't
really get a lot of power in it
until you're older because you have to
be at the same level of the people that
actually own the clubs
they have to be friends of yours that's
part of it they just don't let anybody
in it it's an old boy network
if you're young and successful in the
club in the club industry it's because
you're
young and pretty you're one of those
young pretty girls and you can [ __ ]
call them in
and you're going to be on a box dancing
and which is actually power in the goth
scene
that's social well because everybody
knows you everybody knows you you're
almost kind of like a sales person
well a lot of the gossip and probably
that's true of any industry but it's
it's very socially based real basis
people want to work with people that
they
know them right and it's like a bunch of
local celebrities and
we're going to have a great this night
and this night at this club and this is
who's going to do the posers and this is
who's going to be spinning
and these are the girls that are going
to be there [ __ ] dancing and this is
you know and this one's coming and this
band's going to come and they're going
to show
and this is what this is what the old la
scene was like yeah it's like a long
time ago just somewhere else now well i
mean that's how i ended up
doing record companies aren't involved
that's how i ended up doing
posters and album covers and stuff like
that for all of these local
you know bands and like florida bands
and stuff because everybody knew us
yeah it's gangster [ __ ] but yeah you got
to come up in this scene you have to
have a street cred you have to be able
to be trustworthy
because jenny will tell you right now
i'm i'm cutting right to the quick
the main reason why people don't make it
in the scene it's because they
will run their [ __ ] mouth on social
media
that's the problem if you can't keep
your [ __ ] mouth shut
you ain't gonna make it well and i look
at all those djs that didn't make it
because [ __ ] the running their mouth
on facebook causing drama and the entire
[ __ ] crowd turns against them because
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
why were you saying that [ __ ] in public
what skirt were you trying to talk your
way up well i feel like that was mostly
that's the problem some of the people
that were they're just constantly trying
to talk their way up some [ __ ]
somebody's skirt by train then it causes
a
lot of djs that make it or either
[ __ ] girls
attractive girls who are cool or they're
couples the guy
is a part of a couple well yeah i think
that's why
demetri keeps getting hired is because
he's not trying to [ __ ] everybody
yeah well he has a beautiful wife who is
also in a band
yeah and he doesn't go around like
running after
yeah these young girls like young girls
on this thing which is like i said
[ __ ] is one way that you're gonna get in
big trouble
because the only way you're gonna get
these young girls is you have to fight
your way through a sea
of young guys and when you start
fighting your way through a scene of
young guys and you're already ugly most
of your chances
dudes we're talking about that are
[ __ ] up like this they're ugly so
they can only fight their way through a
scene of those guys by talking [ __ ]
about them which causes a
goddamn war well because nobody likes
nobody likes
a backstabber and i feel like
well like i said i think the reason that
dimitri is still around and he still
gets you know he's still got momentum
memento is still going after what six
seven years
yeah which is unprecedented for a goth
knight really
yeah um is because he's a nice person
nice guy and he doesn't start drama yeah
and like i said he has a gorgeous wife
and
who is also awesome everybody knows them
you guys have seen
her yeah yeah they've been over here
many times they're they're like are some
of our best friends i've seen a lot of
the photographs of jen
jen and jen her name is jen yeah her
name is also yeah
they're they're french so
yeah you know it you really have to
you have to kind of play politics in the
gatsy nobody just like some [ __ ]
that turns up
and is it either is a try hard or
you just show up out of nowhere and
think you're going to swing your big
dick around
yeah and everyone's just going to fall
at your feet that shit's not going to
happen
although i will say that the orlando
scene
in general yeah see that's jen that's
jim she's in a band called 13th angel
check them out yeah let me see if i can
get given her a plug
i do some of their graphics as well yeah
and she's
she's a lovely lovely person her and
demetri are just lovely people
yeah i love them um oh look what she's
got
what does she got right next to the well
yeah
yeah see that's that's us from uh
mannequin a couple days ago that was
just
uh yeah that was uh last week no the
week before yeah
with my red wig yeah and by my wednesday
adam sitting above here this is the dj
booth sitting up here is demetrius
spinning
so plus dimitri is a good dj yeah he's
good dude
he uh he mixes stuff up real good and if
he it's funny because if he knows that
i'm there
he'll play he'll throw some nick cave on
for me like early in the night [ __ ] like
that
whatever it is yeah say oh yeah yeah and
show him that one
that's right a couple years oh [ __ ] oh
you [ __ ] it up [ __ ] that [ __ ] up you
did
and i was gonna say that picture too i
did that uh i did that
graphic but that photograph was actually
taken right here
yeah right here in this right here in
this house yeah this is you wouldn't
know it because i cut us out of the
background but you know it's a couple
about what three four years ago
something like that yeah that was the
scroll at overseas yeah dimitri goes by
dj leviticus by the way yeah
scroll over so you can see like mumbai
tomorrow yeah jenny made that
yeah that's one of the graphics that i
made for memento a couple years ago i
took this photo actually
no i think brian brian oh that's right
brian took that one yeah that picture
yeah yeah we used to have uh back in the
old days we would have
uh photographed and parties
and jen would come usually laura would
come
yeah um because i think that we have a
bunch of other photos from that
era thank you tila because it's payday
and on the second libation of the night
here's dimitri
yeah that's demetrius dimitri he's lost
a lot of weight since this actually
dimitri's uh trimmed down a lot remember
you noticed that we saw him
just a couple days yeah a couple days
ago we're always competing we're always
uh he he's competing with me guys
man you're looking good come on he's
like i gotta stop eating
yeah he's a he's a greek american
very greedy we're always making greek
jokes yeah and they got a
they got a daughter she's [ __ ] cute
little thing yeah gets in trouble but
she's cute
i gave her a bunch of my shoes yeah
remember that when you get older
yeah she cuz they they couldn't find a
babysitter what she didn't really need a
babysitter she was like a teenager
she was probably like 13 or 14 at that
point oh here's a good picture of jen
here you go here you go here you go t
there's a snow buddy for you yeah
yeah yeah she goes by jen draven yeah
the name river band again 13th angel
13th angel yeah
yeah they're also a good band yeah
and um yeah and she's so she's like
operatic vocals and stuff
yeah and she plays keyboard as well and
um she's actually worked with like some
kind of big names like in synth pop and
[ __ ] like that so yeah
yeah she's not that you know she's
actually well known yeah what's funny is
that you know
has been around as long as we have we
just kind of take it for granted that
everybody's well known
yeah it's like oh you guys people would
be like oh man you're hanging out with
them they're like well yeah
it just it just kind of yeah it happened
slowly they came to our house and ate
curry yeah
well it's just like i said it's kind of
like i was going to say what i was going
to say before i think and i'm not sure
if it's really like this because i've
been in tampa for a while
but the perception that i got which kind
of makes me laugh because that old snl
like goth talk sketch
and they were talking about the orlando
tampa rivalry it's not really a rivalry
because
people kind of carry over from both
things i think it was
it was it's not as bad as it used to be
but i do kind of feel like the orlando
scene i mean all god scenes are clicky
yeah um
you know what i mean because this is a
very closed group of people
yeah a lot of the people in the scene
here have you know grew up here
or have been here for years and years
and they kind of know everybody and if
you don't know everybody from this place
you know everybody from the other city
that you came from
the other side of town and they know
everybody over here it's a [ __ ]
extended family yeah so um
i always did kind of feel like the tampa
scene was a little more clicky than the
orlando scene
but maybe that was just because i grew
up in daytona and orlando
and i didn't and i went to tampa but not
as much
so i didn't get to know people over
there as well as
i know people in you know kind of the
orlando area and
you know deland deltona kind of area so
maybe that's why
you know because they were seeing me as
an outsider
a little bit people weren't like [ __ ]
to me or anything like that but it was
just it's harder to
get into that [ __ ] because they've all
known each other forever too and i think
like the same thing kind of happens in
orlando
where if a new person shows up you're
like where'd you come from who do you
know
yeah everybody's like who are you like
do you know anybody that we know
anybody look wrong they don't even ask
that question they're just like forget
about that
nobody will be mean to you everyone will
just kind of like give you the cold
shoulder a little bit
and if you try like i said we've had
people
too that um
you know if we get an eye bar or
somewhere and
you know everybody kind of knows us we
know everybody that works there we know
the owner everything and
sometimes people will come from like
another place
and then they'll kind of try to get in
good with somebody and then they're like
really really try hard like they'll just
come over and like try to talk to you
even when you
clearly don't want to talk to them or
you're talking to somebody else or
whatever
and they'll try to sort of be obnoxious
and like i said kind of throw their dick
around
then uh yeah that's never gonna work out
but you know like i said it's it's just
like anything else you kind of have to
i can't believe that package isn't here
yet well did it say that it was coming
yes it said out for delivery ups it can
be here late
well yeah ups i think they don't come
until like
it could be still light out there eight
or nine o'clock yeah it's still light
out there so
i like these yeah these are pretty good
yeah mango says tom is on the money with
that
i don't know i don't i don't know what
it was though because i didn't see it
and i'm like scared to touch anything
because i'm afraid it's gonna [ __ ]
go tits up on me again how long have
been streaming this time
um let's find out just an hour and a
half okay it's short still
all right yes leaves and cheese is
talking about back then
gots would catch hell yeah
it's really not like that anymore um
we could be out there goffed out like a
[ __ ] and basically the warlocks
will ride by on their [ __ ]
motorcycles because
what one club where tom's bar let me
tell you something
[Laughter]
tom tom right now is probably
the first black goth club
owner that i that i've known all right
and that is in warlock territory and
they're an outlaw motorcycle gang
yeah the entire that part of the town
closes down after like about
11 yeah because they don't want warlocks
in those places at night tom invites
them right at [ __ ]
they love tom yeah well
big tom is awesome yeah and he's a nice
they like his place they like him
and the warlocks kind of had a
reputation for being a racist
they're white trash i want to say that
in a [ __ ] bad way i'll tell them that
you know we all ride motorcycles anyway
you know what i mean [ __ ] him
well [ __ ] i'm white trash yeah
they [ __ ] love tom they love tom well
i think
the thing about big tom i mean he had
been talking because we met him and gina
at ibarr yeah and they had been going
there for [ __ ] ever
i mean they were some of the first
people we met there probably
i mean they've been going there for
years and years and i so i always knew
for
years that that was his big dream
because he [ __ ] loved eyebar he loved
all that 80s music he loves all
of it and he just kept saying to us all
the time when i open my own club and
open my own club and we knew he would do
it one day and then he finally did uh
you know
bite the bullet and do it and one of the
things it seems to me
that that was really important to him
was he really liked
the inclusiveness of the goth scene
yeah i know i just said that it's like
really clicky and stuff which
it is but race is not a factor but in
another way it's also like really
inclusive like i said particularly um
ibarr
because i bar they're kind of like yes
they do 80s night they do a goth night
but they do other [ __ ] too they
um you know they have other they do like
mac and cheese which actually is one of
their most popular right so they have
like a lot of
just a regular kind of crowd but
i mean you can turn up that like trans
people turn up there's like there's a
big gay contingent there's a big so
and everybody is just kind of like
whatevs it's all freakazoids
yeah it's just like whatever it's just
any misfits or outcasts or
anything like that it's you know yeah
but it's also kind of famous people too
it's just it's they're you're not being
judged
by [ __ ] that you can't change about
yourself all right
yeah every everything kind of goes right
they're they're just
um it's all about respect which is the
best thing about
if you if they like your style and you
respect them they respect you
it's like that and like you said you go
in there and try to treat it like a meat
market i'm gonna [ __ ] all these [ __ ]
women oh you're gonna be out of there
yeah you're gonna get it while they're
not [ __ ] you're gonna get in big
trouble the more skin you see the harder
it is to get that girl
yeah the harder it is going to get that
girl do you remember the one
the one night the one night it was just
that on expert
yeah that's a good way of putting it
and then uh but when tom opened that up
man he kept throwing money at me he had
me a whole big old [ __ ] wad of cash
wanted me to manage the place
and i'm like dude we're friends i can't
work for you
and i kind of think he got insulted i
had to talk with him that last time
remember that yeah we talked to him just
on friday i think he got insulted that i
wouldn't take his money like i didn't
want to work with him and
i i was junk enough i said look tom i'm
glad you're [ __ ] here tonight because
we saw him we ran into him at
uh at independent and i said
yeah this is and i said i don't want you
to think i don't want to work with you
so i want to work with you you know but
i'm your friend
you know what i mean and uh you can't
throw a whole bunch of money at me
and then us remain friends and you
become a boss
and then and then i told him i said
another thing is is that i was i
said i said your place made it and it
made it under your own power
and i said you were just trying to give
me that money because you were you were
afraid you were gonna fail you wanted a
white face up there in the front
house and he's like no that's not what
it was and i said that's what i think it
was
and i said those people [ __ ] accepted
you just on you you didn't need me
you didn't need you didn't need it he
just opened a cool bar you opened a cool
bar you don't need a white face up there
you [ __ ] you you made it with you you
make it [ __ ] on your own
and he liked that he's we're gonna work
together since that's right
yeah because we we can work with him our
own services
and because we all gonna do our own
thing together and i said yeah well like
i said i think that was one
and i think that he really did succeed
in doing that because i think that was
the thing that he liked best about ibarr
was that
like i said no matter what you looked
like no matter what your [ __ ]
race sexual orientation anything as long
as you were cool
everyone was cool with you yeah you know
what i mean it didn't matter like what
some culture you were from it you know
it was not it was just a very
that extended out that extended outside
that got the goth scene that even
extended into the outlaw biker scene in
that era
area see which i wasn't really sure that
was going to happen
that area is kind of an up and coming
area
it's weird because it's a lot of yuppies
on one hand and then you had those
outlaw bikers there
and then you had tom but they accepted
him
to be honest i would rather hang out
with the bikers
than the yuppies
not you know no and tilted yuppies i'm
just saying those are the people and i
was talking about and i'll get to a gram
there's hammer question uh because i saw
your question i'll get to it in a second
but one of the things i remember we were
at memento mori and you know as a goth
chick
you kind of have the experience of
being at a club minding your own beeswax
dance into some like
sweet tunes or whatever and then some
drunk ass
yuppie dude or frat boy or whatever
comes up
and tries to like dance up all on your
ass and stuff
that is a very very quick way to get
yourself punched in the throat yeah and
i gotta hand it i gotta hand it
i gotta hand it to those bikers they
understood the scene immediately they
were [ __ ] very respectful
well remember they're just like hey hey
how is everybody and then they just want
to hang out like us
where for a while we were going to some
goth nights that you know that imani was
doing
yeah and that was at a kind of a that
was kind of a biker bar yeah
biker and heavy metal and the bikers
there were totally
fine i understood it could totally they
were just like uh yeah yeah all right
yeah
all right so the guys are here i wasn't
really quite sure that
i mean so so i could always and you know
growing up in daytona which is a big
biker haven
i could i would always rather hang with
the bikers than hang with the spring
breakers
you know what i mean like those kind of
drunk frat boy people because those are
the people that are always going to
cause trouble and you know it at the
second they walk in the door
the second they walk in the door their
body language um
the way they walk in they're always kind
of like i own this [ __ ]
and they're always like yelling whoo
and you're like oh are old-fashioned out
of style there i said it
yeah they are that was like something
actually from like my granddad's [ __ ]
generation more even my dad's generation
weren't that bad
now see zanna doesn't worry i'm too
brown to be gods no you're not
yeah you're talking about dude [ __ ] i
think half of them
half of all everybody in our scene is
hispanic yeah
florida it's all cubans and hispanic
people yeah no one cares
um as long as you look cool no nobody
gives a sh
that girl i just showed you
that girl just showed you well i guess
you could say she was hispanic puerto
rican
nobody goes [ __ ] no nobody cared like
it's added that's just added spice man
as long as long as you look cool nobody
yeah
as long as you look cool and you
actually you carry yourself um
and you don't like make an [ __ ]
yourself yeah then everyone is totally
you know
if you know that music you know that
seeing you have friends in that scene
race is not a factor like nothing is no
honestly yeah like pretty like i said
gots are pretty good they'll put up with
pretty much anything
other than being an obnoxious douche
yeah and uh thank you gadgie and yeah
another thing that's funny is it's not
like
it's not like a [ __ ] normal club
you can't tell who's gay or straight you
see somebody you say that dude's gay no
straight as arrow see another dude man
dude's [ __ ] straight nah
dude gay you just you could you can't
tell on the surface nothing nothing is
stereotypical
sometimes you can but there's a lot of
[ __ ] that's just not stereotypical
[ __ ] man the that one that one lovely
lovely
man that works at ibarr garrett yeah
and um he he comes there when he's not
working
yeah and he's a man sometimes he's a
woman yeah something and he
he makes a very very beautiful woman
yeah i must say he comes here with his
boyfriend
he's a male impersonator female
impersonator he's super cute i love gary
yeah he looks like a man
he looks like a man but then he shows up
as a woman looks like a woman
it looks like a good looking woman
actually looks like he looks like one of
charlie's angels
he does yeah well like i said he's got
he's got that
yes you got the whole thing the [ __ ]
and yeah
like i said you got style what's funny
is that you know
in that scene he he shows up like that
it's not even a big deal you talk to him
just like you talk to anybody
yeah yeah yeah it's just another doesn't
matter
yeah i mean you don't read into the [ __ ]
well like i said i think that's the best
thing about eyebar and i think it's why
it's been there more than 30 years
yeah is just because it's one of those
places where you can go there
and whatever you look like
is fine as long as you're not being an
obnoxious duke douche even people that
are like
quote unquote normal looking we had
because we have a lot of friends that
just like dress normal
but they're still cool granthar's hammer
asked a long time ago and we haven't
answered this question it's been asked a
couple times
uh how quickly can you identify a goth
poser
that [ __ ] up shoes [ __ ] up shoes and
black slacks
it's always the shoes yeah shoes the
biggest giveaway
if you don't have [ __ ] badass god
shoes [ __ ] then you know you
you no it's just wrong you don't even
have to like quiz them about music or
anything although we've done that
just to be [ __ ] but um yeah well if
they got up in our face
because we've had a couple people do
that and like try to be all try hard
like i said don't do that
but that's we always used to joke when i
used to go to the castle
you would have people come in and they'd
be like we're going to dress up as goths
tonight and go to the castle
yeah and the second they walk in you
know exactly
you're like look i'm going what they'll
do is
a poser will buy a [ __ ] a decent
jacket
if he's a guy but he's just got a dress
shirt underneath that and some black
dress shacks
slacks and some [ __ ] black dress
shoes
because it's not a countdown i feel like
particularly and this is maybe not as
relevant anymore but i remember in the
90s and the 2000s
you know some people be like you know
let's go to the goth bar
uh tonight and we'll dress up or
whatever so it was almost like putting
on a costume
yeah um so they would just like wear
black [ __ ] you know what i mean so it's
like so it was like a normal looking
dress but it was black
yeah and like normal shoes or they'd
have like those knee-high boots
like black but they weren't they were
just like normal we wear brand name
shoes
it's either demonia or it's new rock
demonia is entry level but they got
expensive ones too well because demonias
are
cheaper they're cheap new rock you know
they're 300 bucks
but they last forever yeah it's real
leather i mean i got that's what i wear
they are really i got i got several i
mean i got demonia one that's your
[ __ ] yeah
those will apply the thing is those
demonia is [ __ ] better for women
because they'll buy a bunch of them they
never they don't wear yeah i have
several pairs of demonia boots
guys you know what i mean you have new
rocks are a little rich for me you have
two or three sets
of boots and that's what you're gonna
run but they're they're expensive and
they're gonna last a lifetime
and they don't really go out of style
all right what the guy what guys are
wearing
women as [ __ ] goes in and out and they
need a bunch of different ones for
different outfits you need white ones
black ones red ones they just need a
bunch of different kinds of
uh so it's demonia or
new rock there used to be another
brand i haven't seen in a while it's
called pentagon remember pentagon yeah
yeah i remember those
they had [ __ ] really fantastic heels
they were like women's they even make
them
fetish [ __ ] boots you can maybe buy
them on the second-hand market
yeah they're around they were expensive
they were yeah um
but i do kind of feel like so tila says
uh ask tom and jenny how to arrive at
the club if you're not dressed goth
i kind of feel like like i said you know
particularly if you go somewhere that's
not
because you know we don't have uh
a complete goth club per se i mean the
castle
is kind of like goth all the time yeah
or goth industrial all the time
uh most of i but you know like our i
bars
like eye bar is mixed yeah you know what
i mean so each night's a little
different
each night's different they do like
different [ __ ]
they mostly it's over they mostly stick
to alternative
indie um you know they'll do like they
do like a cheesy
80s and 90s night that's very popular
i'll have a goth event going on and
you'll have people [ __ ] just from the
street walk in and look at it and then
they'll leave
yeah um so which we don't care as long
as they're not
obnoxious they're not [ __ ] with you i
mean like i said
a lot of the problem arises particularly
this has happened several times at
memento mori which is more of the goth
industrial
night and it's on a monday so it's not
like you know
you don't get a lot of walk-in traffic
but you do sometimes
and the problem arises when you have a
group of people
that are maybe coming from another bar
they usually are
or it's something like a [ __ ] uh you
know like a bridal
part you know party or something and so
they'll all walk in in a group and the
second they walk in the door
they go woo yeah yeah yeah yeah as soon
as you start and then everybody
everybody rolls like that
that's that's some [ __ ] yo no
tila says they're gonna get thrown out
she just googled goths of color and she
saw that there's a lot of stuff they put
yes
it really boils down to what your body
style is
i mean if you're you know if you're kind
of short and stocky there's going to be
certain looks that you go for it's not
so much race
it's it's more about body style um
you know if you're tall and thin it's
gonna it
you're gonna be wearing very different
you can get away with wearing very
different things
you know like uh
like well [ __ ] what's her name played
storm
um crystal crystal yeah
crystal is tall and thin and she's a
model all right she
worked his storm in universal studios
she's a friend of ours we got a picture
[ __ ] me and jenny worshipping her ass
and she hit the barber that just she has
the real
she has a really nice body she has a
fantastic [ __ ] body
she looks like she's built like a super
bottle um
and also a lovely person yeah she's a
lovely person
she married a dude we know named spider
who's an artist yeah and who does murals
and [ __ ]
and uh
she can get away with [ __ ] that most
mortal women could not get away with
oh yeah just in the way she's built okay
um
yeah because she's very very tall yeah
she's built like i said you she's built
like a supermodel
yeah she she could just walk in wearing
next to nothing and if her hair was
right she had the right shoes on that
she would
fly like an eagle in the club
yeah i mean she kind of does that kind
of stuff she looks badass she doesn't
like
she has no hair she's bald but she i
mean sometimes she rocks the bald
sometimes she wears wigs
yeah just depends on whatever she's a
mortal woman
yeah she's an alien i'm going to show
you
i'm going to show you i mean i'm sure
there's like tons of good things yeah
i'm going to show you and like i said
she is also a lovely
lovely person which you know a lot of
a lot of the people in the cnr we
wouldn't hang out with them otherwise
um but yeah i feel like the problem more
arises not so much
you know i like to see everybody dressed
up i do
i don't like to see this kind of
half-assed you know because if i'm going
to go out
i'm going to make an effort and i
appreciate when other people make an
effort
so trigger that's
crystal right there yeah that's her and
then that's uh that's what's her face
right
yeah they were roommates for a while
yeah i'm gonna try to get a picture of
i can't remember what that chick's name
is i don't know her that well uh yeah
she just comes and goes
yeah she's well she's from tampa isn't
she
yeah is she from tampa here's a uh yeah
she's from tampa
i'll probably remember her name like
here's the picture of crystal just in
the in just in street clothes
it's a blur yay
yeah she's awesome i love her let me see
if
she hasn't come out all that much she
works a lot she does yeah yeah she
worked
i don't know if she still works at
universal but um she had a contract with
them for a long time
she plays a lot of different characters
mostly storm i think that was the one
she was famous close up over her face
yeah yeah she's super cute
um yeah and she always looks um
she was walking down she had that photo
of her walking down through the
hotel lobby in that damn near
okay here's my hair in one of her
outfits
that's uh that's a great picture
actually that's probably
is that a universal or is that one is
that like comic con or something i don't
know probably it looks like a convention
yeah i think that's a convention she's
worked at conventions yeah she goes to
all those conventions
some of them she works at though well
remember like this is a good picture
for black panther premiere oh yeah yeah
i remember her talking about that yeah
she works on all these premieres to the
studio center yeah
come on get in there
so she can kind of wear anything
and it looks good lucky yeah yeah trying
to find that one where she was walking
down
there's a [ __ ] great picture of her
walking down the middle of the damn
hotel lobby it might have been a
convention lobby
yeah i mean oh this is yeah okay so
some of her photo shoot because she was
also oh i remember when she was doing
that she did that for
um halloween horror nights well she was
working university
remember she was the voodoo priest oh
that was okay that was that was
universal that was halloween horror okay
remember which i saw that she showed us
the uh the video from that
yeah because i couldn't afford to go to
halloween horror nights but she they did
like a whole like
voodoo oh remember this remember this
thing like the voodoo queen
yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember that
yeah i think that was one of her storm
photo shoots yeah that's it
yeah yeah she got like kind of she was
i don't even know if they have anybody
else playing storm except her yeah
they maybe do but she's kind of like the
main one that's known for playing storm
over there
i don't know how that's all going now
but because i haven't seen her it's been
a long time
i think parks are not doing all that
great i haven't seen her for probably
like six months yeah
at this point but you know
um it's uh yeah tila says those legs
damn right
yeah that's what i'm talking about i'm
going to talk about the difference
between mortal women and and
mortal women well yeah it's like what
well you know most women are not built
that way well that's the thing and it's
like
you know and it kind of sucks because
you know whatever your build is i'm
always just kind of like
there's only certain things you can wear
she can wear anything yeah she looks
amazing
you know what i'm saying
i kind of i feel like i kind of look
good in the in the goth stuff and also
kind of like
maybe more like rockabilly looking kind
of stuff
like that kind of stuff like looks good
on me but so
like a lot of the stuff she wears i
would never be able to pull that off
ever
obviously well just the height
yeah and just yeah she's way taller than
me yeah
and oh there's a lot of pictures of her
um as a jedi at
disney oh yeah that's right because she
was playing she played uh
she played that character from uh clone
wars or whatever
yeah yeah there we go yeah
yeah but uh
yeah i mean that's that's kind of the
thing
it's so like i said it's not like sophie
was saying it's more
for her it was more like an internal
thing and i think that that's more
like goth i mean and i think that that's
kind of the problem that i had
oh what found it where
her walking around and down like that's
right yeah yeah yeah
okay now your average mortal woman
cannot dress like that
and just walk around okay it wouldn't it
wouldn't
it wouldn't work
yeah but obviously it works for her yeah
so but yeah i mean like i was saying and
i think that that was the problem that i
had
um you know that i got kind of cranky
about
when like i said when goth culture went
kind of mainstream in the 90s
and i think that always kind of pissed
me off a lot because i kind of felt like
a lot of people
just kind of you know they kind of
co-opted the look of it because it
looked cool
yeah wow i need that costume for my
bedroom
if you can sport that the way she does
yes you need that
[Laughter]
no need for me said oh god i splooged
[Laughter]
but yeah it's just kind of like uh
i think like i said i think that was i
you know i'm not saying
that because i kind of had a problem too
with people
because sometimes it wasn't usually uh
girls it was usually dudes and like they
would come to
the castle and they'd be like oh well
i'm goth on the inside so i don't really
have to like make an effort no they
don't have that
so they would just like wear a black
t-shirt and i'm just like okay fine
but i kind of like some effort like i
kind of look like the
you know if you're gonna go out like go
to all the trouble and go out
like go to goth club at least like put a
little bit of effort into it so you look
kind of cool you know what i mean you
don't have to like spend
zillions of dollars or nothing but i do
like effort
they're talking about mexican goths yes
there are many lots of mexican goths and
they do the
they do the day the uh the day of the de
los muertos
version of it yeah and um i'm gonna try
to find you there's
i follow some mexican goth girl uh
mexican goth girls i was sent some to
um i
just got to find the profile you'll see
it they do have a look that they do
and it looks good i'm gonna show it to
you go ahead
yeah yeah that's the thing i mean if
you're gonna go out i'm not saying that
i look
gothy 24 7 obviously if i'm just sitting
around the house
but if i'm going to go to the effort to
go out
i just feel like and i think i feel like
that was kind of the first thing that
attracted me to you in the first place
because you looked like you made an
effort
yeah you know what i mean like you know
you'd come to eye bar and you'd be like
all [ __ ] decked out
yeah like in all your [ __ ] fancy
victorian yeah
uh coats and [ __ ] like that and i
appreciate that
so i don't i'm not really into this kind
of half-assed uh whatever
it's also kind of a different era that's
true
you know and but i'm not going to [ __ ]
on you if you just dress
normal as long as you're not an
obnoxious douche as long as you're like
nice
and like respectful and don't make a
[ __ ] ass of yourself
you know what i mean don't walk into the
club going woo don't like going on the
dance floor and be like rubbing up
against random girls asses
don't be like we've we have too there's
this thing where
like yuppy people and it's always a
group it's never just like one person
well sometimes it's one person but
they're usually like drunk
and they'll come in the club and they'll
like start um
dancing but they're they're dancing like
making fun of other people dancing
yeah you know what i mean like we see
that a lot and um
yeah don't do that either like probably
no one will punch you except
maybe shauna yeah shauna shawna will
punch you right but
if she's there but um or at least kind
of
i i might elbow you like passive
aggressively and be like oh oops
you know i might do that but uh shawna
will just punch you in the face
but um if she's there because she
doesn't like that [ __ ] at all
but um you know just don't just don't be
obnoxious don't try to draw attention to
yourself nobody thinks you're cool
nobody thinks it's awesome it's like oh
look i'm out here like dancing like the
guys blah blah blah
long time to get known it's like nobody
likes that everyone just thinks you're
you know a taint nobody is going to like
think you're cool for doing that or
funny
well that's fine i like when you first
show up you're just one of the faces in
the crowd they don't know you
yeah and if they don't know you then
you're not really a player yet it would
take a long time
and the thing about it is that i think
they just come in there and they don't
realize
bro i mean particularly memento mori
most people get the vibe though when
they come in
yeah particularly if they come in and
pull that [ __ ] at memento more
smaller crowd what the [ __ ] i think they
don't realize
if they just wander in it's like
everybody in there
knows each other yeah and if you start
people have dated each other
and if you start pulling some [ __ ] in
there then you know
you're gonna have a bad time yeah you're
gonna either someone's gonna punch you
or someone's gonna report your ass and
you're going to get thrown out
yeah if you start like pulling that crap
because
it you know it just gets to a point
where you're just like kind of sick of
it because memento
it's supposed to be you know the goths
come there they hang out
it's nice to just go and hang out dance
to whatever music you want to dance to
and not get bothered
by obnoxious people so if an obnoxious
people come if they just like have no
patience there's a mexican goth girl
well now there you go all right i'll
show you some more pictures over here
and um okay
yeah just mango says just go and be
yourself
yeah just like i said don't try to like
draw attention to yourself
or act like you're cool or start making
fun of people
or whatever see the d d yeah
los muertos kind of vibe
see there you go
tila says the thing about san francisco
berkeley areas peeps would take pics and
selfies with you and leave you alone
yeah although i still i don't know i
still get a little weirded out by people
because we've had that happen too where
we get some rando coming up and be like
hey can i take a picture with you guys
and i'm just kind of like that makeup
yeah that's awesome looking
it sometimes it makes me feel like i'm
at disney world like a character
you know what i mean yeah like everybody
wants to come up and take pictures like
like we're there for your entertainment
yeah i'm like these are just my clothes
[ __ ] it's like
[Laughter]
i'm not like a costume not paid to like
be here to be in pictures with you
like i know they don't mean it like that
but sometimes i do get kind of salty
about that kind of stuff depending on
how drunk i am if i'm real drunk i'll be
just like get the [ __ ] out of my face
right now but
you know i try to be nice you get the
mexican motif on that it's that same
girl
see now that is badass yeah trying to
get it to focus
that is badass if i could rock that
outfit going out i totally would
there you go so there's a lot of
different ways to do the goth
thing that's a trip
and that's another thing too is i kind
of feel like
maybe people that aren't in the scene
donors it's like really um diverse in
the sense of the like the looks you can
do
yeah that is still considered like a
gothic kind of look
yeah you know it's not just one thing
where it's just kind of like oh we all
have corsets on although i usually do
because yeah
look at that outfit
oh [ __ ] man i turned that turned off
choosing a vaquetto outfit yeah sophie
says find the aspects of goth that
you're naturally attracted to and roll
with it you literally don't have to love
it all yeah you
you don't yeah and the thing about it i
think that
i think it's because when i got into
goth i didn't even realize what it was
because it was the 80s i grew up in
daytona i didn't know anybody that
looked like that
i didn't know anybody else that listened
to that kind of music
it's just that i kind of happened to
stumble across it and i was already into
spooky [ __ ] like i was already into like
the adams family and i loved
that kind of aesthetic like that
victorian kind of look
and i didn't know that there was a name
for it i didn't know that other people
were into that [ __ ] too
so for me it was like real organic you
know what i mean
see oh my god oh my
god that is her outfit
look at that it's got the heart
unexposed on the outside if i could
marry that
outfit i would that's a [ __ ] trip
see this stuff oh see i just drool over
[ __ ] like that
and then she did that
see look at that [ __ ] that's fantastic
that's fantastic
she does other stuff too it's kind of
like uh pinup stuff
i mean [ __ ] man you know very
boob-centric i [ __ ] love boobs
well he loves boobs i love boobs he
loves boobs and buttons yeah
well you know it's like a button you
know he's gonna it's
amy whitehouse was also kind of hot i
gotta say
see this that's fabulous that's [ __ ]
fabulous
see i wish i could i wish i could pull
that off or that i had the money to do
all that kind of [ __ ]
because that's [ __ ] you do you just
need the time you got the money
wow look at that one i mean i try and
then like sometimes
because [ __ ] man if i'm just going if
i'm just going to like the regular club
with mannequins which we kind of feel
like
i feel like i have to dress up if it's
an event
you know what i mean like for vampire
ball i was like oh i better like spend
an extra hour or whatever because it
usually takes me like a couple hours
to get ready but that's just because i
don't like to rush
and sometimes i'll put an outfit on and
be like man i don't like this
see there you go there's some moves okay
there's some boots i gotta check
okay make sure your package came top
heavy then yeah probably her back is
killing her but you know it looks good
anyway in pictures
jenny you should be a goth mummy for
halloween this year i was thinking about
it
well when i was looking into because
like i said when i heard about
the halfway to halloween party which i
heard about it oh
you know it's friday and i heard about
it
a couple days ago because i did the
poster and then i was like [ __ ] man i
gotta like [ __ ] come up with an
outfit
for that and i didn't have any things
that i was like [ __ ] i gotta order
something like right now so i have
something to wear
because i didn't just wanna go in my
normal clothes and um
okay well can't understand maybe they're
just driving around in the truck
and um i thought about doing the mummy
and i was actually going to get a mummy
uh outfit because bride of frankenstein
is kind of
bandagey and mummy so i did kind of look
at like sexy mummy sort of
outfits but none of i found one that i
kind of liked but it was kind of
expensive
then i was like well i don't know i
don't know if that would look really
good i was trying to like
i don't know i was trying to figure out
the best thing so finally i just ended
up getting
just this white it's like a gothy
dress and it's like short in the front
and long in the back like with a tail
like with white lace and [ __ ] and then
it has like strappy
it's long sleeve but then it has like
straps up here and i thought that looked
kind of cool i was like well that looks
kind of bright frankenstein
and because i you know i wanted
something that i would wear
otherwise you know i mean that wasn't
like a costume because if i bought like
a
you know a bride of frankenstein looking
costume i'd probably never wear that
again
because it's kind of baggy all right t
says
well people going tom is too much and
then t that goes boobs
the boobs are too big and yes there is
such a thing and then [ __ ] guys
going tom's uh chicken and boobs and
no i'm just no there isn't it not too
big
i i have never seen tom's limit i i
don't think he's ever seen a woman that
had moved that were too big
yeah no the bigger they are the happier
he is yeah
[Laughter]
well no you you need to you need a woman
that's just all
boob no she's just one big it rolls
[Laughter]
her name is loretta vamps loretta vamps
on on
on uh instagram
yeah mango says all boobs are great yeah
[Laughter]
i mean we're talking about tom hello
yeah it's you know well if the girl's
got problems and said yeah because
big boobs you know as good as they look
sometimes they do come with some
physical issues because they are very
heavy
you know what i mean no i'm just i i i
ha i'm very honest you know what i mean
i have a
i have a boob fetish and i do and i have
a shoe fetish
and not feet he doesn't like feet he
likes shoes like shoes
it's not so bad where i don't need the
woman just need the shoes
they got some guys that just look at it
so bad they're like we didn't even want
them
to give you that goddamn shoe like i
said the women don't the the shoes don't
talk back yeah the woman might well know
that
the woman is in the way of the sexiness
you know they have they're ruining it
they have that
they have dudes that it's that bad no i
just i got a shoe fetish i got a boob
fetish i got a booty fetish
too yeah yeah the rest of it is just
i don't know i don't i don't analyze it
i just roll with it
and and and what i'm not
totally picky about the shoe it just has
to be a part of the theme of whatever
the whatever
the woman's wearing you know i just i
don't know i can't explain it it's all
got to go together it's got to go
together
and honestly sometimes i'll have an
outfit and he'll be like well that's a
good outfit but
not with those shoes not those shoes so
then i have to put different shoes on
you know what i mean
a woman doesn't have to have shoes on
for me to have sex with her
but it's a lot better
a lot better well like i said i think we
brought this up before i have a pair of
shoes
that i've worn them out twice
i think and they've mostly just stayed
in the house
they mostly just stay in the house
because i've worn them out a couple
times
i mean you can but at the end of the
night
i'm one of those [ __ ] that's walking
along the street like half drunk being
like i gotta carry the shoes i can't
wear them anymore
because they're really really they have
this really really tall like spike heels
and they're they look awesome but i walk
around i'm walking around like a [ __ ]
baby deer
yeah in those [ __ ] shoes the more
comfortable they are a lot of times the
more i'm gonna be into them
yeah that's definitely the case it's
kind of like a bondage accessory because
i'm always kind of like man can i just
wear like my flat boots those are cool
looking too at least i can dance in
those
those that's okay yeah i did get a
couple pairs of flat boots that are
really nice and i have some that are
like
that have like wedge heels and those are
fairly comfortable and i can dance in
those
but those like real tall spike heels
they look awesome they're stripper shoes
i got them in a stripper store
um but i've worn them out a couple times
but i always
regretted it at the end of the night
because i'm like god damn my [ __ ]
some of the
killing boots have that same heel
structure that also kind of [ __ ] you up
after a while
yeah oh actually you don't have those
boots anymore do you which ones are we
talking about
the ones that oh no no i guess you could
say the ones with all the spikes on them
that's not the same heel no it's a
platform that's like a that's like a
platform
yeah that's right those are slightly
uncomfortable but
i can usually wear those all night and
dance in them and i'm usually okay like
sometimes my toes will hurt
like the next day if i dance a lot in
them
but i'm kind of going for something that
looks awesome
but that i can dance in without falling
over
when i'm half inebriated and that i
don't to take off
like walking to the car you know what
i'm saying
i don't want it to get like that where
it's like i'm going to be [ __ ]
falling over
when i'm walking out today titus was
lying that he didn't have any kind of
fetishes
yeah she said she was gonna go out yeah
he said he didn't have any
he's lying i don't know if i don't know
every guy has something that
at least one thing that [ __ ] with him
yeah if he doesn't then he doesn't have
any taste in anything
he'll just take anything and i'm just
you know what i mean that means you know
how you taste it well i don't know i
don't well the thing about it is that
certain tastes well yeah but a
proclivity toward one thing is not the
same as a fetish
yeah i guess so maybe although i guess
you fetishized anything
you could argue that it was like a
question of degree though yeah
yeah but like i said when you get into
fetish territory
yeah i think you're talking more about
like what you were saying about dudes
that are into shoes but they're just
they're not even into the woman wearing
the shoes yeah
they don't work they don't need the
woman yeah they just want to see the
shoes they just need the shoe yeah
because they don't even so i gotta have
the woman and the shoe
sometimes i see the shoe and i'll think
of a woman
i'm gonna put these on somebody you know
something like that
i mean i don't know i feel like i don't
know if i have a fetish
i don't know like i'm not yeah you have
a goth guy fetish
i do yeah but as i said not always
because it depends
on how to do this on who it is like i
said i have more of a thing where
i don't know i'm not one of those people
that just like checks out random people
because sometimes you'll see somebody
walk in and be like oh that's a cool
outfit or whatever
but if i don't know that person then it
doesn't really
go any farther than oh that's a cool
outfit you know what i'm saying
yeah i'm not one of those people that's
just like ooh i gotta you know
like i gotta hit that yeah i'm just kind
of like that's a cool outfit
or that looks good on that dude but i
don't know that dude
and he might be a douche most women most
women it's something in their mind
it's a mental thing yeah well we yeah a
lot of [ __ ] has to align yeah
it's because guys are visual yeah our
whole sexual apparatus is very visual
that's cross species that's why fish
male fish are like that
i mean just all it's just tom is like a
fish like a fish
[Laughter]
spock was like a fish he's spawning like
a fish
yeah but just in the sense that i think
dudes are a lot more
they're just kind of like if if it looks
good that's fine yeah
it's good yeah then it's good yeah
whereas women are kind of like well that
helps but
there needs to be other things it's more
complex
you know what i mean yeah although you
know as a man i know just because it
looks good doesn't mean it isn't good
you've seen me before we were going out
that's true i [ __ ] go after one i
know she looks good i can't stand her
yeah i'm only gonna take care it's gonna
wear off
yeah and i know it's gonna wear off but
in the meantime i'm gonna tear this up
and you get sick of her quick you know
what i mean you're like i can't stand
this woman
she's so [ __ ] stupid
that's good yeah i guess so it's kind of
the same it just takes y'all a little
bit longer yeah we got to get out of the
system you know tomorrow
yeah yeah whereas thus we kind of make
all those calculations before anything
really happened yeah
well you guys have something to lose we
don't yeah that's exactly what it is
probably yeah
you got resources to worry about getting
pregnant and everything yeah there's a
lot more
there's a lot more bad [ __ ] that can
happen right so you evolved to weed
those guys out to be a lot more
discernible yeah we
males evolved to take advantage of that
to spread seed get as many of these
[ __ ] knocked up as you can
just spraying what you're trying to do
yeah like should i
get this afraid i'm gonna get this but
just animalistic [ __ ] yeah
you're using birth control yeah
okay it's just animalistic [ __ ] yeah see
sophie said the same thing it's rare as
hell for me to just see a 1010
dude yeah it's just it's it's just like
a different
i don't know it's a different
calculation i have seen that happen that
like
you know like i said i'll be um
you know i'll be at memento or something
like a guy i'll walk in like i don't
know who it is
and i'll just kind of glance and be like
oh that's a cool outfit or that dude
looks good in that outfit yeah
but that's kind of as far then you don't
really think about it anymore have you
guys seen the movie idiocracy that was a
[ __ ] great movie
everybody's in the beginning of that no
not everybody that was a limited release
and uh a lot of people don't even know
about it they kind of put that one on
the shelf you can't even get it on dvd
or on blu-ray i don't think i think it's
only on dvd
and there's a scene there where they're
talking about how any how dumb people
were [ __ ] reproducing faster than the
smart people the smart people had
careers and [ __ ] and they were
they weren't having kids you know they
had their careers and then they had
they showed us one scene and this this
exemplifies the [ __ ] basic
male sex drive [ __ ] some
white dude i kind of remember what his
name what his name was
in the cletus or whatever there was
cletus or something
cletus is done he won the [ __ ]
football game he's got
cheerleaders on one so he's got a
[ __ ] black one and a white one
underneath his [ __ ] arm and he's
running off we won the game he's going
whoo i'm gonna [ __ ] all y'all
remember that i'm gonna [ __ ] oh yeah
which is exactly the type of
dude that i can't see yeah but but it
was those were the ones that got
reinforced
yeah genetically i'm a [ __ ] all y'all
and then he uh was then he uh hurt his
nuts
got his nuts [ __ ] [ __ ] up because he
tried to jump
um he tried to jump a swimming pool in a
[ __ ] fort with a four-wheeler
and got impaled on top of the uh uh
fence and uh you know by the
br great brilliant work of these two
doctors they were able to rest
make him functional again and they're
showing his family tree getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger
and you know just that's kind of what
nature
[ __ ] you know and then the doctors
didn't have many kids but this [ __ ]
cletus
he's just looking his his family tree is
getting huger and huger
thousands of years later [ __ ]
everybody's dumb as [ __ ] it's called
idiocracy it's a great movie
well like i said see that's exactly the
type of dude that i would run
very very far away from yeah it doesn't
matter it's a numbers game oh i know
i'm just saying first of all yeah
personally i would run
very very far away from that because
that's exactly the type of dude that
comes in memento sometimes and everyone
and everyone rolls their eyes yeah
hilarious hell yeah
nope yeah i mean maybe that [ __ ] flies
in like some other
clubs yeah probably oh yeah
maybe that's why they do it because it's
like they're used to doing it they're
doing that
in other places and people are like oh
yeah i suppose so
yeah but you come in like a place like
that and do it and everybody's just like
yeah why do you think
why do you think yeah you're projecting
your standards
on these people they do that because
that's a successful thing that works for
them
for the club that they [ __ ] came from
you know with a bottle in the hand and
they're dancing they're got
their nurses their cars are shorts yeah
and the girls got their purses hanging
in their
their polo and they're three of them
facing each other dancing at each other
[ __ ]
with all their purses in the middle it's
just sucking
[ __ ] taking up the whole [ __ ]
dance floor yeah those are the kind of
people that i elbow passive aggressively
and then if they say anything i'm just
being like oops i didn't even see you
there she's lying she stays at the
[ __ ] bar
with me just looking at it going well no
well i used to do that
i used to do that i don't do it anymore
i don't want to get in trouble it's just
yeah but you know that that's happened
then you got jimmy buffett [ __ ]
coming up dancing with him
oh my god florida florida man do you
remember the one time
this was an eye bar i don't remember was
this i don't even remember who says
this wasn't memento i think it was the
80s i think it was 80s night so i think
it was a saturday we're sitting here
live streaming making fun of the
mundanes and i bet you're [ __ ] 20
40 of the damn audience probably that's
okay we're not talking about you guys
you guys are cool right you guys are
cool you wouldn't do that obnoxious
intuition
since i got to see this movie yeah man
it's called idiocracy you will learn a
lot from that movie
everything in that movie is true
everything everything in that movie is
true and it's funny as [ __ ] it is very
funny
funny as [ __ ] when the world gets taken
over by idiots it's idiocracy you see it
happening now
just today in today's world you see it
happening it will happen
that's why civilizations rise and fall
[Laughter]
too many goddamn dummies everybody girls
quit stop sleeping stop sleeping with
idiots yeah but um
stop making dumb ass children
[Laughter]
yeah knock it off make sure everybody's
smart yeah but um
yeah so yeah that's the thing do you
remember that one i think
this is going back a couple years but
you remember
there was a dude and it was early in the
night too because i remember not that
many people were there
and like some good song was on and i was
out dancing and there was only like a
couple people dancing because it was
like pretty early
and like this dude comes up and he did
that thing where they he they
come up behind you and then they're like
bumping up against your ass and whatever
oh yeah yeah
and i was just kind of like something
that here we go it's a great strategy
you know
here we go yeah and um before i knew it
yeah tom he was standing by the wall
had come out because i kind of looked at
him like what the [ __ ]
is this the last time we were there no
this was this was a couple years ago
okay this was several years ago yeah and
you grabbed the dude by the neck
and threw him oh me yeah yeah put you in
big toe
yeah you did yeah i remember across the
dance floor
and he slid yeah then them lesbians ran
up to me because that was the [ __ ]
coolest thing ever yeah they did
[Laughter]
because that dude was like because i'm
sitting there i'm like just dancing
minding my own business it was a good
song right
yeah and i was just i was only a couple
feet from you because you were like
leaning against the wall and i was
dancing or whatever and this dude just
comes up
like um did i tell you that you could
touch my butt no i did not
he's a big old fat dude so yeah and he
you just went
and he just slid pushed him off his
center of gravity and [ __ ] through
this
and then i love the face they make like
what what did i do then the bouncers
escorted him out they throw the whole
thing
he got kicked out i know all the
bouncers in front of it you can't [ __ ]
with them in the club
well because they know that if you did
that then that dude was doing something
well remember i've bounced [ __ ]
you have yeah in front of the bouncers
okay good good job don't
just [ __ ] out of here i just know
the doctor was like what do you do oh
he's [ __ ] being okay
just like what's watching people yeah i
don't understand like where
like what the [ __ ] kind of savage place
did you grow up where that was okay
yeah i don't really understand i don't
know like i said i i think there's still
a perception and it's probably not as
prevalent as it used to be but there
used to be a perception that
you know kind of goth chicks were [ __ ]
so not with you [ __ ]
exactly and it's like and like i said no
you know [ __ ] no shame against [ __ ]
that's
awesome but it's just kind of like you
know that she didn't say that that was
okay for you to do
you're not in the game you know you're
way low on a [ __ ] totem pole you're
[ __ ] at the bottom of the food chain
that girl don't want you
yeah like where like i told you that was
all right to do yeah like don't go
touching people you don't know who they
are man that shouldn't even need to be
said but apparently it does
[Laughter]
grampher says i'm probably a mundane but
not full blown one day
so uh how long we've been streaming do
you guys wants to keep going or you want
to end the stream what's the deal
we still got a pretty big crowd in there
that's awesome how long
how uh how long have you been two hours
and 20. this is a big [ __ ] show
well it's a wednesday show yeah you know
what i mean no need for me says they're
going to get some schnapps to put in
their coffee i think that's what that's
right we got a new [ __ ] super chat do
we really okay you're a couple
seconds ahead of me then because i don't
see it yet mango [ __ ] said oh thank
you mango go ahead and read it
great show loving the goth club tales
seen and been involved in the same
situations in the uk
[Laughter]
love to the chat you guys are great yeah
i do kind of feel like that
is maybe universal to like got people
everywhere
yeah all the goth girls have some kind
of story
about something i probably told this one
before but one time i was at eye bar
and you were in the bathroom yeah and i
was sitting at that little table like
waiting for you to come out of the
bathroom
they're saying don't leave and i got
okay no we're not leaving
okay um and you were in the bathroom it
was like five minutes dude yeah
and i got surrounded by three
dudes like three like yuppie dudes yeah
i don't remember it
well because you were in the bathroom
okay and they came up with like i was
just sitting there smoking or whatever
and then they come up and like that and
they're just like hey
and i'm just like yeah go away like you
know i remember that the more you
go away they wouldn't go away they
wouldn't go away and i was just like i
couldn't get away there
i was like surrounded and i was just
going oh [ __ ] this is this we've had
girls do that too
oh my god remember that go away oh no no
no no no then they
insist not [ __ ] go away you know
exactly what i'm talking about
her and her sister yeah remember that
and then you guys
like i don't understand why i told that
story they knew who that is
just they probably i don't understand
why you tell people to go away just go
away if i tell you to go away i mean it
go away
there's a girl that [ __ ] got furious
that i started going out with jenny
she would we'd be riding in the car and
[ __ ] she and i
i didn't have anything really to do with
this woman all right i called her a girl
she was a woman
and she'd be calling me on the telephone
yelling at me through the speakerphone
jenny sitting there hearing the whole
[ __ ] thing that's [ __ ] glare
cracking up yeah crack it up and then
[ __ ] we come to the show and then she
tried to [ __ ] strangle jenny
remember that well she tried to throw
that you throw her you threw her off the
stage
i didn't throw her off this thing that
was funny what happened was
and this and this was the culmination it
wasn't like i just did that
out of the blue yeah i mean he's asking
for it
i don't have a lot of patience i will
say that and the older i get the less
patient i get
yeah but i had put up with this chicks
passive aggressive [ __ ] for probably
a couple of years at this point
because she was like into you she was
around for a long time and for some
reason she had still thought it was like
1998. she was stuck in 1998.
remember that it was 2008.
she's about ten two thousand later today
because i didn't even meet you until
2010 or 2011.
we started going out mid 2011. okay so
it was 2011. that's when that happened
and so she'd been around for a while she
was like super into you
yeah and you were kind of into her like
at the beginning
uh more she talked the more she started
[ __ ] it up
annoying i did mess around with her a
little bit but it didn't really
yeah because then that was before me and
you because i was still with that like
kind of sorted in that other guy
she was cute she yeah she's a
good-looking girl
she's not ugly or not she's cute um but
she had mental problems
and i like i from the time first time
that i met her
i was just like man that [ __ ] is
annoying and i was like i couldn't put
my [ __ ]
finger on what it was but i was shooting
man in your face wouldn't shut the [ __ ]
up
and she would yeah and it's just kind of
like i don't know it was just like this
weird narcissism or whatever
and it's like she would just like talk
and talk and she was just like super
annoying she wouldn't go away when you
said it was just like she's just a
really abnormal your sister was just
like her
yeah we met her sister one time just
like but it's like so she so we i try to
make peace with her look man
well do you remember like back in the
day like because at that time we were
kind of hanging out but we weren't going
out
yeah and you know you'd be like oh you
know
you should be nicer to him or something
i was like man you know if i
if i don't like you and you rub me the
wrong way from
the from the jump um
it's pretty much impossible to get back
into my good graces if you've made that
much of a bad impression on me from
from the first yeah um uh you're never
going to get me to like you
so just stop we got we got to [ __ ]
rename this goth or not that's what
somebody said there
where's the trivia where's the trivia
question well we did some
they're getting bored with that early
they're getting bored with these stuff
with with these uh club stories
so we weren't they weren't there yeah
should we do more trivia do what you
want be able to arrest him but no but
what i was gonna say was that
yeah so i had put up with this bitch's
[ __ ] for a long time and then
um oh my doorknob fell off
all playing you did oh my god you're
just you're so big and strong you just
pulled the doorknob right off
so yeah so she had like been doing this
for years and i've you know he was like
why are you trying to be nice to her i'm
like you know
if i decide i don't like you then it's
really hard for me to decide that i like
you or be
nice to you it's just really hard for me
to be nice to people i don't like
so i was just like can i just ignore her
is that fine so i try to do that but
you know she wouldn't she'd get all up
in your face and you don't like me i'm
like yeah you're goddamn right i don't
just get
the [ __ ] out of my face so one night
um i was kind of drunk and she was maybe
drunk i don't know we're on something
and she kind of like did one of those
you know oh oh an accident blah blah and
she like knocks into me and i'm just
like okay that's enough and then like i
just pushed her i didn't push her off
the stage
but i kind of grabbed her by the neck
and i was just kind of like hanging her
like off the stage like what the [ __ ]
are you doing
and then she her eyes got real big and
then she complained about me but nobody
did anything because
you know they all know me so um
you know what i mean so it was it was
that kind of thing i think she's gone
now i think she
married somebody and moved to germany or
some [ __ ] like that so
i don't know where she's at now but yeah
she was and then one night she brought
her sister there
and her sister was just as obnoxious as
she was
just one of those people where it's like
you don't want to talk to them but they
won't
they won't take no for an answer they
keep wanting to get up all up in your
face you're trying to talk to somebody
else they're trying to like intrude in
your conversation it's like why won't
you talk to me watch it and i'm just
like
why should i have to talk to you and
it's like really really obnoxious and i
really hate that she always had to kind
of be the center of attention
and if she wasn't she'd get like really
mad about it and wonder why
you weren't paying attention to her
which
made me hate her even more but you know
what i mean but uh yeah
so there was that whole thing so if you
guys want me to do more
trivia then i will do more trivia i
don't know why i can't get this other
this game was working like the other day
i had this because this other game like
i had a free one and i had one that was
99 cents
the 99 cent one was better because it
had more questions
and i felt like the questions were more
challenging
but for whatever reason i couldn't get
it to work like i was trying to answer
the questions and it was just like
looking at me like okay but yeah i don't
want to do that
so what'd you do oh you finally
okay yeah so there it is oh it's
unboxing
yeah got that blade it's in here i got
it it's in here
it's in here i'm just gonna use brute
force there you go
so i'm gonna see if people want some
more horror trivia questions then i will
go back and we're at level eight
these are on a timer though it's not
in army of darkness what is the correct
phrase well it's claturata
yeah which was from today the earth
stood still right yep
claw tube
your luck just ran out is one of the
taglines
for leprechaun child's play 3
child's play 2 or leprechaun 2.
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna go with the first
leprechaun is it the first leprechaun
yes it was that was a good guess what is
michael meyer's
signature weapon hook bowie knife
machete or kitchen knife
i'm going with kitchen knife on that one
that is correct
i don't know don't like the film how
many wrong turn movies are there by now
2018 uh
[Music]
see that i don't know three nope six
what okay what's the nickname of the
killer
in the silence of the lambs that's easy
buffalo bill obviously tooth fairy grim
sleeper green river killer no that was a
real dude
it's buffalo bill everybody knows that
maine and tag oh what is the main
antagonist in the maniac cop franchise
i've only seen the first of those that
it was a long time ago
yeah there were six of them i can't
believe that i'm guessing this one
uh matt cordell oh that was a total
lucky guess that was correct
which of these films is probably easy
which of these films is directed by
alfred hitchcock
queen of the damned obviously not prince
of darkness no
psycho obviously poltergeist three
make these harder where does one of
these
never go you're making too much noise i
do what i gotta do
where does one of the ghoulies comically
pop up that's a toilet
because i remember that uh cover from
the back in the day
um oh [ __ ] bobby carter
doug wood ruby brenda carter are
survivors
of which horror movie
bobby carter doug what is that is that
hills have eyes
yeah ruby yeah yeah yeah hills have eyes
yeah yeah
all right survivor of the original texas
chainsaw massacre i'm going to look
that's sally
hardesty that's yep
uh okay now i have another ad
can i close that or not
i wish the other game worked that didn't
have ads in it
i restarted the phone but it's still not
working it was working the other day i
don't know why it's not working anymore
these ones are like not as hard
the other one's harder but
we'll see what's in the box
i've never seen the ghoulies i think i
saw the first one
but i don't know did i
i kind of feel like back in the video
rental days
i kind of rented all of those and not a
lot of them
like stuck with me to a point where i
still remember them this many years
later
you know so i probably saw ghoulies but
because i feel like after gremlins came
out it's like everybody's let's do
ghoulies let's do hobgoblins which is a
terrible terrible movie although
the mystery science theater episode they
did of it was like one of the best
mystery science theater episodes
i love the cheesy 80s movies
on mst that's like my favorite genre
it's cheesy 80s movies and hobgoblins
is the cheesiest most terrible
i mean they're just obviously these
little puppets and they're awful
the character jason voorhees was played
by whom
in the 1988 film friday 13th part 7
the new blood was that kane hotter yes i
feel like that was kane hodder's first
movie
as jason the seventh one which of the
following horror movies is canadian
house of wax the fog suspiria
or black christmas black christmas
obviously
yes that is correct which one of the
following final girls made an appearance
as a little girl and friday the 13th
part six jason lives
that would probably be lori i'd imagine
yes
no what no
janet lee jamie lee curtis and tom
atkins together
star in which of the following movies
that's probably the bog yeah
yeah the fog right yeah they were all in
that movie huh
huh what wow i just came here and you're
asking questions
the 1981 film the evil dead was directed
by who
i don't know sam raimi okay you didn't
know that
yeah i'm looking i'm really pretending
you should ask me these questions alfred
hitchcock
directed rod taylor in which
film well it's obviously it's the entity
the descent the amityville who are the
birds they really need to have better
choices on this because that's obviously
the birds
the other ones aren't even alfredo
chicago
ooh okay i don't think i saw this movie
or no maybe i did in silent hill
what do you notice about the nurses in
the hospital
they're all midgets bedside manner
bandaged faces or no medical insurance
it's bandaged faces right yeah yes
what's the name of the fifth movie in
george romero's
living dead series survival of the dead
diary of the dead land of the dead or
day of the dead
ooh is it land or day was land of the
dead was the fourth one two three four
i think it's diary of the dead isn't it
yes
okay who directed the 1998
film psycho that was gus van sant was it
not yes
that was a totally pointless remake
which hopefully everyone will agree with
me on that
wasn't a bad movie it's just i didn't
see the point of it which of the
following characters
uh oh has the most appearances
in the final destination franchise
that i don't know because i only saw the
first one
wendy christensen kimberly
corman alex browning or clear rivers
i'm totally winging it nope
clear rivers the [ __ ] name is that
whatever
i gotta pee okay good talk about
something
how are you doing for a drink
damn that thing's still going over there
yeah um i was um
hold on yeah i was walking xanada
through a
a dissipater build he put in an order
through psa and uh got the wrong
order a dissipater upper didn't come
instead a bunch of other [ __ ] came
[ __ ] um
a 300 blackout uppercase
and 300 blackouts [ __ ] expensive as
[ __ ] right now
so uh you know i guess he got that i
guess he got a dissipater it must be a
psa dissipator
he hasn't shown it to me yet
i got i got one of those dissipater with
a [ __ ] old uh with the older uh
70s 70s and 80s style
collapsible on the back of it carbine
tube
[ __ ] got the tungsten buffers in
there
like in good springs but what i was
doing right now
is i was taking a psa mid length
pulled the [ __ ] front block off of it
i'm going to put an adjustable block on
it and put a free float
just run right running a regular a2 a2
flash compressor
but uh i'd like to see xanada i'd like
to see your dissipater bro
pm me a photograph of that [ __ ]
i [ __ ] got old furniture from the
[ __ ] 80s
the with the a little slimline [ __ ]
cult handguards
got a bunch of that kind of [ __ ] let me
get some for [ __ ] uh
xm 177 reproduction i'm building
okay go ahead but no and answer your
question grant there's
no i don't give a [ __ ] i do not give a
[ __ ] about that uh
about any of those rulings i don't think
it'll pass anyway
and i would be in a sanctuary state i'm
not worried about anything they say
i don't give a [ __ ] about nfa either
that was from another era and that's
that's going to be a ticking ticking
clock there they'll
they're i don't see how they're gonna be
able to enforce any of that anymore
as time goes on
and it'll be state by state go ahead
somebody said something about candyman
remake it's actually not a remake it's a
sequel
um i saw a trailer for it a long time
ago when the theaters were still
open i don't remember i don't know if
jordan peele
directed it or if he's just producing it
looked good though
it's a kind of it's about the baby that
got
saved from the fire in the first one is
grown up now and they even have like the
same actress that played
uh the baby's mom i can't remember what
her name is but she was in the original
candyman
so it's gonna be it's like a
continuation it's not a remake
um which i don't know i i don't really
have a problem with that
i don't know if they're gonna get tony
todd back as candyman
he's kind of i don't know how old is he
now
i don't know 60s probably yeah because
candyman was
90s yeah so a long time ago yeah but
i don't know yeah somebody else could
play him but i do kind of feel like that
voice is like so iconic
you know what i mean yeah um
tila says strike that he co-wrote the
screenplay
yeah i kind of want to see it looked
good i mean
you know so i'm not gonna [ __ ] on it
till i see it
and like i said if jordan peel's
involved it's probably gonna be at least
decent
and i like that they're not remaking it
i like that it's like a continuation
because candyman is you know
it's it's an urban legend story and i
like urban legend story so you could
like take that
in another direction and they never did
any
no they did do a sequel didn't they
farewell to the flesh
which i think i saw but i don't i don't
know if it made much of an impression
i don't know that's another one that i
probably need to see again because it
might be better than i remembered
i just remember it being okay
zach says good news i went on a date
earlier how'd it go
oh my goodness you gotta tell us how it
went zach
we want to hear all the gossip or you
know
as much as you're willing to share ed
warren uh is a character from
the conjuring cabin in the woods black
swan 28 days later
obviously conjuring he's also a real
dude he's a demonologist
wes craven directed heather graham
in which film saw
six saw five scream two
or shrooms
was she in scream too i'm gonna guess
that because i don't yeah okay that's
right i didn't remember heather graham
being in scream too
get away from her you [ __ ] is sigourney
weaver's famous quote from aliens alien
3
alien or alien resurrection that was
aliens
was it not yes
countess dracula bathes in what
virgin's blood obviously goat milk about
15 minutes i like that that was one of
the choices
[Laughter]
somebody come up with some questions for
me two main protagonists in night of the
living dead and its remake are
francine and peter harry and helen
cooper judy and tom
barbara blair and ben
was her last name blair maybe well ben
was that guy
so okay that's what i was guessing
uh harry warden is a secondary
antagonist from
oh i know this one prom night house of
wax when a stranger calls
or my bloody valentine do you guys know
i know
it's my bloody valentine yes it is
i just saw that movie not too long ago
uh
which character from saw franchise
was portrayed by shawnee smith amanda
young jill tuck
allison carey or tatum riley what the
[ __ ] was her name in that movie
god it's been such a long time since i
saw
saw amanda yeah i'm okay that was a good
guess
which 1978 film was directed by john
carpenter
halloween four return of michael myers
obviously not right from hell obviously
not right halloween
obviously is the right answer fright
night is obviously the wrong answer
and then where does the actor what
where does the actor take place in
resident evil
i don't that doesn't make sense maybe it
means maybe they mean action
somebody whose english is not their
native language wrote this quiz
gotta be what it is is just spell check
went through [ __ ] and past stuff let me
have it let me have that
maybe what you want the lighter of me oh
okay
which of the following horror movies
zach galligan doesn't
appear in okay he was in gremlins
he was in gremlins too waxwork i think
he was in that too army of darkness he
was not in that
somebody said you're so right tom i
don't know if i could talk about it
unless you talk about spell check
people going through a spell check so
i'm right about that yeah
well remember that one question that i
had before that was something like
i don't even remember like what it said
but it was like some weird kind of
fractured english some of these are good
questions but like some of them
some of them are too easy and then some
of them are like
so hard that like nobody would know why
is this not working okay my [ __ ]
shit's not working anymore
that's kind of what i encountered i was
doing like i said i was doing some
horror trivia quizzes online
and they were either the questions were
either so easy
that like duh but then the other ones
were kind of like
which movie made more money like and
then it would give you four choices i'm
like i don't [ __ ] know
jesus christ it was and it was that kind
of [ __ ]
you know what i mean i feel like there
was no in between but you know what it
got me thinking
i was watching this um this video i
can't remember the name of the channel
it wasn't one i was subscribed to it was
just one that i
found when i was like searching horror
trivia and it was like i said it was
these three guys and they play
board games just like on a show and they
were playing a horror trivia game
as i said they weren't horror nerds so
they were doing really badly
like even some of the easy questions i
was just like jesus christ i couldn't
believe like they didn't know the
answers they were young too so maybe
that's why
but um i thought to myself i was like
well [ __ ]
i you know i could do a horror trivia
game maybe i should do a horror trivia
game
i did an edgar allen poetry video game
called red death
yeah which i think is up for sale if you
really want to make money on what you do
is you make it
an app well i was thinking about that
too like i was thinking about that
earlier when i was
awake and i was like man maybe i show
her a trivia app well you can make a
board game an app
well yeah you could do both things well
there's a lot of things that are a board
game but that have like an app that's
like a
you know like a suburb about looks like
a board game but it's actually an app
yeah okay i mean like a fake board game
it's got graphics
yeah and it's an app that you download
okay mango says here's one for you who
was originally cast as frankenstein's
monster
i want to say oh
man i want to say that it was
it was one of the other horror stars in
that day i want to say it was some it
was like basil rathbone or somebody like
i don't think it was basil rathbone but
i think it was somebody like that
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] man tila's
saying tom too stuck up to smoke a joint
that's kind of right though i don't
[ __ ] like that when we
i'm not yeah like like i said and i'm
not like i don't [ __ ] on people that are
into it because everybody has a
different
everybody has a different thing because
some of our well and some of our friends
are really into it and i get that but
it's just like i don't
really it doesn't affect me in the same
way that it affects them it's like it's
not
i would like it if it chilled me out but
it doesn't
well they're gonna start all kinds of
war in there fighting in that group
about how good wheat is
i'm just not a big weed person she
doesn't really like it that much i
prefer alcohol but
if you give me a choice to alcohol weed
i'll take the alcohol
yeah me too um they're still those are
still kind of like
lower echelon basic
basic [ __ ] drugs i mean that's just
basic [ __ ] you know what i mean [ __ ]
i don't like any kind of ghetto drugs
i'm not entertaining that crack or
[ __ ]
yeah i'm not gonna take any of that [ __ ]
you know yeah you might need my face off
the only good ones are either very
expensive
and habit-forming and so you have to be
really careful with them
or they're hallucinogenic which means
you can't go anywhere you have to stay
at home
yeah you don't want to be [ __ ] high
on these drugs so i can run around in
public you get your [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
get yourself get your [ __ ] killed
that's what happens to you know you'll
get killed eventually well like i said
i'm really
worth it i'm really glad like you know
when when i did lsd i was really glad i
went right around loose
somebody asked who directed the man who
laughs oh [ __ ] i know i
oh i know this i know this no there's
nothing in there i know this
is i remember conrad white was in it
because he was also in the hands of
orlac
who the [ __ ] drawing did that oh
damn i can't remember i
it wasn't myrnow the same guy that did
not do who the [ __ ] was it
[ __ ] man now i can't remember i can't
remember yeah pat says do more trivia
please
like i said i like when people in the
thing you need to you ask me the
questions
you do it me because it's not fun just
me i gotta work and read
and [ __ ] oh my god i think that's
something you have to work for a living
[ __ ] join the rest of us plebes yeah
you know what i'm saying actually again
it's getting late
it's getting late do another level or
two claire spencer
is a character from what let me in
uh let the right one in or what
lies beneath or you're next clear answer
i want to say it's your next but i might
be wrong look
it went red i guess it means no that's
wrong it was one last beneath okay who's
the killer on friday 13th in 1980
pamela where he's yeah got that one
right
uh who asked carrie to the prom johnny
timmy tommy or tammy
tommy of course tommy ross same as your
name yeah
that's how i always remember derrick
carter and juna kaplan are characters
from the ring
one missed call the descent the grudge
sarah who sarah kurt and judy kaplan
juno i think that's the descent
yep okay okay
uh what's the name of the priest that
appeared the most in the exorcist movies
father father damian karrus
father delaney father david bennett
father lancaster merlin well marin died
in the first one so i'm assuming it's
karis
because he was in the third one well it
was marin
that's [ __ ] who's the main
antagonist in the hitcher's movies
michael meyer john ryder
mickey adler or george meeks the second
one
john ryder yeah rucker howard was in
that chat the original halloween mask
was based on leonard nimoy william
shatner william shatner's face i don't
even need the choices for that one okay
in house of wax the antagonist uh prof
uh professor jerry or henry jarrod
uh was most obsessed with what marie
antoinette
abraham lincoln joan of arc and queen
victoria oh [ __ ] was it waiting
time with the original or the remake i
guess so uh
joan of arc nope it was marie antoinette
i thought that first but oh well how the
killer in black
christmas killed his victims uh no how
the killer in black christmas calls his
victims oh angela amy mary or
agnes angela mary
yeah that's how he called him
[ __ ] agnes
yep oh okay you guessed well i thought i
had seen that movie but i couldn't
remember construction two
when what destination final this
destination two what ultimately kills
brian
an exploding barbecue an ice skater a
truck or a loudspeaker
oh [ __ ] i don't think i saw that movie
i'm gonna guess
an exploding barbecue yeah okay right
because it's almost well because it was
the wackiest one and that's kind of like
that's
what final destination is all about
doing wacky [ __ ]
yeah so how'd i do on that one i got
seven points on that
level all right so what's
about you but i'm not getting hungry are
you getting hungry
yeah we ate a long time ago
i got that homemade hummus sitting in
there
oh i forgot and then i also have
fresh um uh what do you call them
cucumbers make a hummus and cucumber
sandwich oh my god we need to do that
what is the name of the book from the
evil dead franchise
the necronomicon yeah everybody knows
that yeah
in which movie we can see i'm just
reading it like it is
freddy's glove leather faces chainsaw
chucky's doll
michaels and jason's masks
versus jason jason goes to hell the
final friday halloween resurrection or
bride of chucky
uh you know what i kind of feel like
maybe
it's freddy versus jason nope pride of
chucky
wait really okay i didn't remember that
which of the following horror movies
bruce campbell doesn't appear
i'm not [ __ ] that's just
uh wax work maniac cop evil dead too wax
maniac
was he a maniacal i don't know i don't
remember him being in the first wax work
maniac see i was right
which actress played sydney in 1996 film
scream that would be nev
campbell yep what are you having with
the hummus i was thinking about um
having uh making a uh
putting it on toasted pita and the
inside
with uh slices of cucumber in there
see that sounds really good i didn't oh
i forgot we had cucumbers yeah
fresh ones
cucumber and hummus
what is christine plymouth firebird
plywood fury plymouth fury pontiacs it's
a plymouth area
um
this is an ad words with friends
okay that was the end of that level how
many levels are in this thing
a lot that's pretty cool a lot yeah it
is pretty rad what okay let's shut this
down
you sure yeah all right yeah we're going
to shut it down we've streamed long
enough i'm having a good time but okay
christine is a great movie yeah it is we
did a review of it i feel like that was
kind of like
an underrated john carpenter film and an
underrated
uh stephen king adaptation one of the
better ones christine was actually a
masterpiece if you go and watch it
it's done really well especially
compared to the crap that they make
today
it's actually very good now not
everything that they make today is crap
but they make a lot of crap today
well they made a lot of crap they made a
lot of crap back then it was worth it
it's worse today well
it might just be worse today because
there's more of it yeah
i think that's the issue more than the
quality i think there's just like
yeah but christine had big big bigger
hollywood names in it that was a
hollywood product
that's a lot better than the [ __ ]
that they're making today i mean i think
this year [ __ ] sucked this year
[ __ ] sucked
now this is a week year for hollywood
but it's just
it hollywood's gone off the [ __ ]
rails
yes yes i've i've seen the numbers
seen the numbers for the oscar awards
saw uh what
what each studio made they made movies
that nobody saw that people
didn't even know about a lot of the [ __ ]
that they didn't [ __ ] think was going
to make any money or that they were
deriding made a [ __ ] ton of money like
godzilla versus kong they didn't think
that was going to make any money
made a [ __ ] done well we still need to
see that because i heard that that was
good
those studios are [ __ ] up they don't
know what they're doing well and nobody
knows
what's gonna hit yeah i mean
you see sometimes they spend a [ __ ] ton
of money on something that they think is
gonna be like a [ __ ] ace in the hole
it's gonna
be like in the bag but then it's kind of
a big so what
yeah because you know like we've said
before the more money you spend on a
movie
the more your ass is on the line so you
have to kind of make it palatable to
everybody and if you're trying to make
it palatable to everybody then it's
going to be palatable to nobody
yeah and it's just going to be kind of
generic santa says he's still got a
bunch of [ __ ] that i was told him to
watch yeah i got a whole list man you
need to see hamburger hill dude
man i got a whole list too i'm trying to
work my way through
he's watched uh books and movies
watching apocalypse now redux over and
over again he loves that movie
and you haven't seen jeremiah johnson
you haven't seen [ __ ] conan you
haven't seen
hamburger hill and some of those other
two were from
john millions movies you know you're
you're [ __ ] up you just [ __ ] up you
know
well you only have so many hours in the
day yeah and the thing about time
he's got time that's a young man he's
got time oh i think our [ __ ] crashed
it's time for us to go all right well we
were gonna stop anyway yeah
all right so hopefully you guys can
still hear us i think they can we'll be
back again
on friday evening talking about
alienware nose yeah so be sure to tune
in for that i'll probably be dressed as
a bride of frankenstein so don't be
alarmed
uh so yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by thanks for your donations hopefully
you can still hear me like i said
yeah because our [ __ ] crashed didn't
hear antsy okay awesome
it's it's back but yeah good because my
shit's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] up so we might do more horror
trivia if i can get that other game to
work
it was working earlier i don't know why
it's worth not working now but whatever
it was it was like a more expansive kind
of game
but yeah we will get back into it later
on
we will see you guys on friday thanks
everybody for dropping by have a good
rest of your day and we will see you
later
[Music]
bye